Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten und ich begrüße alle zur 126.
Ausgabe von Raumzeit.
Und nachdem wir uns jetzt viel mit Teleskopen beschäftigt haben in den letzten
Sendungen, gehen jetzt Schockwellen durch die Raumzeit und zwar literally und
das die ganze Zeit und das auch schon seit einiger Zeit.
Und ich habe schon häufiger darüber berichtet, über Gravitationswellen.
Darüber wollen wir uns heute ein weiteres Mal unterhalten.
Und dazu bin ich nach Görlitz gefahren zum Deutschen Zentrum für Astrophysik
und begrüße meinen Gesprächspartner für heute, nämlich den Günter Günter-Hasinger.
Hallo, grüß dich und schön bei euch wieder zu sein.
Ja, wir hatten schon mal das Vergnügen vor vier Jahren tatsächlich.
Da war ich in Madrid und da war es nun auch...
Da war ich Wissenschaftsdirektor der ESA.
Genau und da haben wir uns viel genau darüber unterhalten, aber vor allem auch
über das James-Webb-Teleskop, was ja damals frisch gestartet war und ja mittlerweile
kann man sagen auch schon eine ganze Menge von den Versprechen eingelöst hat.
Ja, eigentlich nicht brechen, sondern das hat alle Erwartungen weit überragt
und vor allem diese Objekte im frühen Universum,
die sehr, sehr vermutlich irgendwas mit schwarzen Löchern zu tun haben und das
passt natürlich wunderbar jetzt auch zu dem Thema mit den Gravitationswellen.
Genau, darüber wollen wir uns nämlich unterhalten aus einem anderen Grund.
Also erstens ist es immer schön sich darüber zu unterhalten,
aber es ist jetzt ziemlich genau zehn Jahre her,
dass das erste Mal es gelungen ist Gravitationswellen zu entdecken oder zu messen,
also konkret zu detektieren und ist auch ziemlich genau zehn Jahre her,
dass ich dann auch darüber eine Sendung gemacht habe.
Das war im Februar 2016,
also ist diese Detektion stattgefunden und ich bin dann schnell zur ESA gereist
und habe dann Gott sei Dank auch gleich einen kompetenten Ansprechpartner zu dem Thema gefunden.
Ist ja nicht so schwierig, gibt ja ganz in Reihe.
Also es gibt tausende von Wissenschaftlern, die sich damit beschäftigen.
Du hast mit Oliver Jenrich gesprochen.
Genau, mit Oliver Jenrich und das war auch eine interessante Einführung.
Alles natürlich noch aus dieser Perspektive heraus, dass man jetzt gerade mal
sich sicher sein konnte, so okay, die Theorien haben gestimmt,
wir haben es jetzt irgendwie auch hinbekommen, die entsprechende Technik zu
bauen, gucken wir mal, was kommt.
Weil man wusste ja nicht, ist das jetzt so ein totaler Zufall gewesen und man
hat jetzt irgendwie mal eine gefunden und jetzt dauert es wieder 20 Jahre,
bis die nächste vorbeikommt oder ist das jetzt sozusagen so ein Dauerereignis?
Die Existenz von Gravitationswellen war ja vorher schon im Prinzip bekannt durch
diese Doppelpulsare, die also Energie verlieren und wo man also sagen konnte,
dass es genau so ist, wie Einstein vorhergesagt hat.
Aber dann war die Natur tatsächlich sehr gut zu uns und hat eben dieses fantastische
Ereignis mit zwei schwarzen Löchern, die jeweils ungefähr 30 Sonnenmassen hatten, gefunden.
Und da sind alle Leute aus allen Wolken gefallen, weil solche schwarzen Löcher
hatte man vorher noch nie gesehen.
Und das war eben jetzt heutzutage ganz Standardmöglichkeit.
Dass eben LIGO solche schweren schwarzen Löcher findet.
Genau, da kommen wir noch zu. Sprechen wir mal erstmal kurz hier zu dem Ort,
weil der ist ja noch relativ neu, das Deutsche Zentrum für Astrophysik hier in Görlitz.
Ja, warum, weshalb, wieso gibt es dieses neue Institut? Was ist hier die Aufgabe?
Genau, also das DZA, Deutsches Zentrum für Astrophysik, ist eines von zwei Großforschungszentren,
die im Rahmen des Strukturförderungsgesetzes Kohleausstieg in einem Wettbewerb ausgesucht wurden.
Da gab es also vor ein paar Jahren einen riesen Wettbewerb, da gab es so 100
Bewerber und wir haben uns riesig gefreut, dass wir dann letztendlich in zwei
Stufen ausgesucht wurden als eines von diesen Zentren.
Es steht da ziemlich viel Geld zur Verfügung. Also die Bundesregierung hat entschieden,
ungefähr 10 Prozent der Kohlestrukturfördermittel in diese Großforschungseinrichtungen zu stecken.
Das heißt, wir haben 1,2 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung, über 15 Jahre ein großes Zentrum aufzubauen.
Das soll insgesamt ungefähr 1.000 Leute haben zum Schluss. Und wir sind inzwischen
schon von 0 auf 110 gekommen.
Also wir haben jetzt 110 Mitarbeiter hier im Zentrum von Görlitz und haben natürlich riesiges vor.
Wir wollen Multimessenger-Astrophysik machen, also Radioastronomie,
optische Astronomie, aber die Gravitationswellen spielen eine ganz zentrale Rolle bei uns.
Und das hat dich dann auch bewogen, den doch ganz interessanten Job bei der ESA aufzugeben.
Na bewogen kann man so nicht sagen, also der ESA-Job war von Anfang an zeitlich
limitiert, die haben ja ziemlich strenge Altersgrenzen und ich bin da natürlich
drüber gerutscht. Stutt.
Aber umgekehrt, ich hätte schon noch ein paar Jahre bei der ESA machen können,
aber diese Chance hier, etwas völlig Neues aufzubauen, kommt halt nur einmal im Leben.
Also das war wirklich dann das, was uns bewogen hat.
Wie geht man da ran? Ich meine, wenn man so ein Institut komplett von Null aufbaut?
Also zunächst mal muss ich sagen, haben wir uns auf eine unheimliche Unterstützung
der ganzen deutschen Community stützen können.
Und ich bin ja nicht allein, ich habe ein fantastisches Team,
da sind ungefähr zwölf Professoren aus allen möglichen Institutionen in Deutschland.
Max Planck, Helmholtz, Leibniz und die Idee, so ein Großforschungszentrum für
Astrophysik aufzumachen, ist
schon lange in den Strategiepapieren der deutschen Community gestanden.
Also ich war selber ja mal Ratsvorsitzender der Deutschen Sternwarten.
Die schreiben so alle zehn Jahre so eine Strategiedenkschrift und da stand immer
drin, wir brauchen so ein Zentrum.
Und das passte halt einfach wie die Faust aufs Auge. Also als dann diese Kohleausstiegsmöglichkeit
sich ergab, da mussten wir uns bewerben.
Ja, also Zentrum für Astrophysik, man würde ja erwarten, dass Astrophysik als
solche schon seinen Platz hat in der deutschen Wissenschaft.
Insofern, was fügt das Zentrum dem dann noch hinzu?
Also genau, die Astrophysik in Deutschland ist eigentlich sehr,
sehr gut aufgestellt, vor allem durch die Max-Planck-Institute von Anfang an,
also Radioastronomie, extraterrestrische Physik, optische Astronomie, Gravitationswellen.
Die auch schon Nobelpreise reingeholt haben und so.
Und auch die Leibniz-Gesellschaft, also in Potsdam, das war ich ja auch früher
mal Direktor an dem Institut, ist eigentlich sehr, sehr gut aufgestellt.
Aber was es nicht gibt...
Und gab, ist eben ein nationales Zentrum, was die Community in großen internationalen
Projekten vertreten kann.
Also die Max-Planck-Gesellschaft kann praktisch keine Serviceleistungen für die Community,
bieten und das ist so ähnlich wie in der Teilchenphysik, da gibt es ja das CERN
als riesiges internationales Projekt,
aber das DESI ist einfach die nationale Vertretung der Teilchenphysik und ist
sozusagen dann im internationalen Rahmen satisfaktionsfähig und sowas gab es
bisher in der Astronomie noch nicht.
Und das Deutsche Zentrum soll das jetzt im Prinzip machen, diese Rolle.
Also wir reden von diesen riesigen Projekten wie SKR zum Beispiel,
Square Kilometer Array oder auch das zukünftige Einstein-Teleskop,
wo wir dann quasi die nationalen Interessen vertreten können.
Da werden wir jetzt auch noch gleich drauf zu sprechen kommen auf diese Projekte.
Aber jetzt müssen wir natürlich erstmal ein bisschen das Feld legen,
denn so Gravitationswellen ist so ein bisschen eins meiner Lieblingsthemen geworden
hier bei Raumzeit, muss ich sagen, weil es halt einfach,
naja, ich meine, es ist halt neu, aber es ist halt auch irgendwie total faszinierend,
dass es das überhaupt so gibt und es ist noch viel faszinierender,
dass es jetzt auch gelungen ist, das zu messen.
Denn es gibt ja im Prinzip, basiert das mehr oder weniger auf Voraussagen von
Einstein von vor ziemlich genau 90 Jahren tatsächlich.
Und gesagt hat, so ja hier Gravitation und so Relativitätstheorie,
so stelle ich mir das Universum vor.
Hat sich ja auch weitgehend bestätigt bisher, was er an Ideen so formuliert hat.
Und die Gravitationswellen waren eher so eine Fußnote, sage ich mal.
Das müsste es eigentlich auch noch geben aber das ist ja kaum zu messen,
Ob man das jemals finden wird, who knows.
Also in der Tat hat wohl Einstein schon gesagt, dass es sowas geben muss,
aber es hat niemand geglaubt, dass man es je messen werden könnte.
Und es ist heutzutage noch fast so unglaublich, welche Präzision da drin steckt.
Also es sind ja 10 hoch minus 21 ist die relative Längenänderung von irgendwelchen
Maßstäben, die durch die Gravitationswelle entstehen.
Und 10 hoch minus 21 ist also auch eine unvorstellbar kleine Zahl und eine unvorstellbar
hohe Genauigkeit, mit der diese Geräte arbeiten.
Genau, jetzt sollten wir nochmal sagen, was es ist. Also es gibt große Ereignisse
im Universum, die so viel Energie freisetzen,
dass da nicht nur Dinge abstrahlen, man kennt das ja mit irgendwelchen Gammastrahlen
Und alles mögliche Puls,
aber bisher haben wir das Weltall ja eigentlich primär so über elektromagnetische
Strahlung aller Art wahrgenommen.
Also Licht natürlich, aber was in anderen Frequenzbereichen noch so zu holen ist.
Aber nachdem man wusste, dass das Universum oder unsere Annahme derzeit,
die sich laufend bestätigt, ich muss jetzt schon Wissenschaftler-Sprache sprechen,
ist, dass wir eben diese Wirkung der Gravitation haben, dadurch,
dass der Raum gekrümmt ist oder gekrümmt wird durch diese Gravitation.
Also sprich, da wo viel Masse ist, wie zum Beispiel unsere Sonne,
krümmt sich der Raum so, dass die Erde, die eigentlich immer geradeaus fliegen
will, um die Sonne drumherum fliegt.
Also dieses Bild der Kugel auf so einem Stück Stoff, was halt irgendwie alles mit sich zieht.
Und diese großen Ereignisse lassen halt diesen Stoff vibrieren in kleinen Stoffen.
Vielleicht ist es ganz interessant, weil es gibt nämlich sehr gute Analogien
zwischen der elektromagnetischen Strahlung und der Gravitationsstrahlung.
Also eigentlich ist es beides dasselbe, nur dass im einen Fall sind es elektrische
Ladungen, die sich verändern.
Also wenn irgendwo ein Elektron zum Beispiel von einer Schale auf die andere
hüpft, dann muss dem Rest des Universums das mitgeteilt werden,
dass sich sozusagen jetzt die Ladungsverteilung verändert hat und das wird in
Form von elektromagnetischen Wellen gemacht.
Wenn ein schwarzes Loch von einer Seite auf die andere springen würde,
dann muss der Rest des Universums das sozusagen auch mitkriegen und diese Information
der Änderung der Gravitation wird eben über Wellen nach außen gesendet.
Man kann sich jetzt eben vorstellen, so eine Art Gummi, wo diese schweren Massen
drin liegen und dann fliegt das eine um das andere rum, dann wird der Raum sozusagen
verändert, die Krümmung wird sich sozusagen immer verändern und das wird dann
in Form von Wellen nach außen getragen.
Eigentlich wie so Wellen, wenn ein See oder ein Wasser Wellen wirft,
wenn man einen Stein reinschmeißt.
Und wie das Licht ist die Ausbreitung in Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit, genau. Das konnte man ja wunderbar jetzt messen und
bestätigen durch das erste Ereignis, was Gravitationswellen und Licht gleichzeitig ausgesandt hat.
10 hoch minus 21, das ist ja immer wieder so eine Zahl, die kann sich kein Mensch
vorstellen, beziehungsweise was das bedeutet.
Wir reden hier von einer Erschütterung unseres Raums und damit ja sozusagen
einer Ausdehnung, wie so die Effekte, die man so im Film Matrix sieht,
wenn Neo alles verzerrt, genau,
nur mitnichten in irgendeiner Form sichtbaren Ausdehnung.
Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt vor den eigenen Augen alles wabert,
sondern wir reden hier von einer Distanz, die sozusagen kleiner ist als die
Ausbreitung eines Atoms.
Ja, also man kann sagen, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel 10 Kilometer Armlänge hätte,
wo die Laserstrahlen hin und her sausen,
tausendmal, dann kommt man auf 10.000 Kilometer und die Änderungen,
die man sehen möchte, ist ein Millionstel eines Atomkerndurchmessers.
Das heißt also, das gibt dann schon so die Größenordnung an 10.000 Kilometer
auf der einen Seite und beides kann man sich nicht mehr so richtig vorstellen
und jetzt verbindet man die beiden Sachen, kann man sich erst noch weniger vorstellen.
Genau, dafür ist dieser Podcast da, um Sachen zu erzählen, die man sich nicht vorstellen kann.
Aber naja, wenn man jetzt vielleicht mal die konkrete Skalierung ein bisschen
rauslässt, dann versteht man schon, der Raum zittert und man will dieses Zittern messen.
Vielleicht kann ich da eins noch dazu sagen und zwar die Gravitationswellen
haben eine ganz wichtige Charakteristik und zwar wenn man sich so einen,
sagen wir mal, dieses L-förmigen Detektoren vorstellt, die die Wellen messen,
wenn der eine Arm kürzer wird, muss der andere automatisch länger werden.
Oder wenn man einen Kreis hernimmt und eine Gravitationswelle geht durch,
dann wird die so elliptisch verformt, dass der Kreis sozusagen immer senkrecht
zu Ellipsen gezogen wird.
Und das ist eine ganz, ganz wichtige Geschichte, weil damit kann man Störungen
von anderen, also Gravitationswellen haben eben diese ganz besondere Charakteristik,
wo man sie raussuchen kann unter sehr, sehr viel Rauschen, was sonst noch existiert.
Genau, weil die beiden Detektoren, die die erste Gravitationswelle gemessen
haben, die basieren ja genau auf dieser Idee.
Man hat halt einfach einen langen Laser, den man über ein paar Kilometer rausschickt.
Das waren glaube ich vier Kilometer. 4 Kilometer.
Also es ist eigentlich nur ein Laserstrahl, der durch so ein Prisma geteilt
wird, das heißt die eine Hälfte geht in die eine Richtung, die andere 90 Grad
davon entfernt bis zu einem Spiegel,
dann wieder den Weg zurück und
wenn es halt jetzt in irgendeiner Form eine Änderung in diesem Raum gibt,
Dann ist die eine schneller als die andere. Und wenn man dann eben diese beiden
Lichtwellen wieder übereinander legt, hat man so eine Phasenverschiebung und
das ist eigentlich das, was man misst.
Genau, also wenn man Exaktes übereinanderlegt in diesem sogenannten Michelson-Interformator,
das wurde ja auch vor ungefähr 100 Jahren erfunden,
dass derselbe Laserstrahl praktisch aufgeteilt wird mit dem Strahlteiler und
dann wieder mit sich selbst verbunden wird, dann muss das Signal Null sein sozusagen,
weil die Wellen sich gerade so wieder gegenseitig überlagern,
dass nichts übrig bleibt.
Und wenn man dann eine winzig kleine Störung hat, dann kriegt man eben ein kleines
Lichtsignal und dadurch hat man schon mal einen riesen Hebelarm,
mit dem man dort das Signal messen kann.
Und ja, das ist sozusagen das Prinzip und das ist das, was vor zehn Jahren zum
Einsatz kam und es gab auch nur genau diese beiden Messgeräte.
Wenig überraschend gab es dafür dann den Nobelpreis im Jahr drauf schon für
diese Forschung, weil das natürlich monumental ist und vor allem ist es ja dann eben auch so die,
Geburt einer ja einer komplett neuen,
Wahrnehmungsfähigkeit Völlig neues Fenster.
Was da aufgegangen ist Vielleicht sollte man dazu sagen, dass da 30 Jahre Arbeit
vorangegangen sind also das war ja sozusagen, als dann Advanced LIGO das gemessen
hat, da gab es ja vorher schon viele Generationen von anderen Gravitationswellendetektoren.
Und da hat ja auch zum Beispiel das Geo 600 in Hannover, was du auch schon besucht
hast, eine Rolle gespielt, weil diese neuen Detektoren, die da bei Advanced
LIGO eingesetzt wurden, dann eben den Durchbruch geschafft haben.
Also es sind einfach, man muss eben riesige Berge von Rauschen erstmal überwinden
und nach unten klopfen, bevor man dann das Signal bekommt.
Genau, weil das kam ja auch schon in der ersten Sendung hier zur Sprache.
Diese Vibrationen, die man dort sieht, die kann halt von allem kommen.
Irgendein Hase läuft an der Installation vorbei, Wellen treffen auf die Küste,
paar hundert Kilometer entfernt, aber egal.
Der ICE-Fahrplan, den kann man dort auch sehen.
Nur dass all diese Änderungen halt nicht immer eine Änderung in beide Richtungen bringen.
Und das ist sozusagen die Basis, dass man das alles rausrechnen kann,
aber man muss es dann auch noch rausrechnen.
Und dann hat man eben bei der LIGO zwei Detektoren, die tausende von Kilometern
entfernt sind und wenn der eine so irgendeine Erschütterung sieht,
die nicht aus dem Weltall kommt, dann sieht das der andere nicht.
Aber wenn es wirklich aus dem Weltall kommt, dann müssen sie beide gleichzeitig sehen.
Und das Das ist der Grund, warum man halt mindestens zwei braucht,
beziehungsweise das ist auch der Grund, warum man dann auch gerne noch mehr als nur zwei hätte,
weil dadurch, dass diese Gravitationswellen sich natürlich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit
ausbreiten, was ja erstmal sehr schnell klingt, ist das trotzdem schon in unserem
planetären Maßstab so ein Unterschied.
Das heißt, kommt die Gravitationswelle aus der einen Richtung des Universums
und eine andere aus der anderen, dann hat man unterschiedliches Zeitverhalten
bei den einzelnen Detektoren.
Also zunächst kann man sich das ja vorstellen wie ein Mikrofon,
was einfach allen Lärm hört, der aus allen Richtungen kommt.
Und wenn man dann zwei Mikrofone hat, dann hat man ja schon Stereoinformationen.
Und ideal ist es, dass man drei oder vier hat, sodass man eben die Lichtquelle
oder die Gravitationsquelle möglichst gut am Himmel festzurren kann.
Es gibt Frequenzen letzten Endes in diesen Wellen und wenn man dann wieder das
so vergleicht mit Sound oder so, denkt man sich so, ja okay,
gibt es dann also unterschiedliche Frequenzen.
Dieser ganzen Detektion ist ja auch noch was vorhergegangen,
was ich auch extrem faszinierend fand, dass man ja sagen könnte,
okay, wir werden da irgendwas messen.
Die Frage ist, wie sieht das aus und was können wir daraus ablesen und dementsprechend
ist ja viel Arbeit geleistet worden auf der mathematischen Ebene, dass es,
wenn ich das richtig erinnere, zwei unabhängig voneinander arbeitende Teams
gab, die sozusagen diese Frage beantworten wollten, die also quasi rein mathematisch
gesagt haben, ja okay, wenn es das gibt,
dann müsste sich das bei dieser Messmethode auf diese Art und Weise niederschlagen.
Das heißt, das Bild, was man letzten Endes sieht in dieser gemessenen Frequenzänderung,
sieht so und so aus, je nachdem, welches Ereignis man hat.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass das natürlich im Endeffekt dann extrem relativistische Vorgänge sind.
Also man hat dann sozusagen Krümmungen der Raumzeit, die fast 100 Prozent sind,
man redet ja von schwarzen Löchern und es war lange Zeit nicht möglich,
solche Simulationen tatsächlich dann mit der richtigen Physik zu machen und
das war, bevor die Entdeckung dann kam, war das ein Durchbruch,
dass zwei Gruppen praktisch das geschafft haben,
wirklich allgemein relativistische Simulationen von solchen Vereinigungsprozessen zu machen.
Weil wir ja hier jetzt ein Audio haben, ich kann mal versuchen,
das vorzusingen, wie so ein Signal klingt.
Also wenn man zwei schwarze Löcher hat, die sich einander umkreisen,
das ist ja wie so ein Sinussignal. Also da gibt es so ein tiefes Brummen.
Und dann kommen die langsam näher, weil sie Gravitationswellen verlieren,
also Gravitationsenergie verlieren.
Und dann wird das Brummen etwas höher.
Und dann haben sie sich miteinander vereinigt. Und dieses Zip,
das nennt man ein Chirp, wie ein Vogelswitschern.
Und das war praktisch, diese Simulation hat eben diese Chirps vorhergesagt und
das war genau das Signal, was man dann gesehen hat.
Und das alles einen Tag, nachdem man die neue Technik installiert hat und alle haben sich angeschaut.
Ja, es war noch gar nicht im offiziellen Messbetrieb.
Und es war auch interessant, dass die beiden Herren, die das erstes gesehen
haben, waren in Hannover gesessen,
weil das ist ja ein internationales Projekt und die Messungen laufen praktisch
Tag und Nacht über und während es in den USA noch Nacht war,
saßen die hier in Hannover und haben das Signal praktisch gesehen und erstmal
überhaupt nicht geglaubt, aber das war wirklich fantastisch.
Kann man sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen, wie es den Leuten in dem Moment ging.
Aber wir reden ja jetzt dann auch über, wie es heute aussieht.
Und vielleicht kann ich da eine kurze Brücke schlagen. Ganz vor kurzem hat der
neue LIGO-Detektor, also der wesentlich empfindlicher ist, fast exakt das gleiche
Signal gesehen, was damals.
Also entstanden ist mit 30 Sonnenmassen, zweimal 30 Sonnenmassen.
Inzwischen ist die Signifikanz der Messergebnisse dramatisch verbessert worden
und jetzt kann man alle möglichen hochinteressanten Dinge aus diesem Signal
ableiten, die man am Anfang noch nicht konnte.
Also das ist eigentlich eine schöne Brücke, dass wir heute zwar immer noch diese
Signale sehen, aber inzwischen mit wesentlich höherer statistischer Aussagekraft.
Genau, das ist ja auch im Wesentlichen der Gedanke jetzt dieser Sendung,
dass wir ein bisschen drauf schauen wollen, was eigentlich sich jetzt in diesen
zehn Jahren getan hat. Dieser Chirp,
Also nicht nur, dass man jetzt daran sieht, okay, so sieht das aus,
wenn zwei schwarze Löcher sich miteinander vereinigen, sondern man konnte ja
auch schon diverse Parameter daraus ziehen, nämlich in etwa,
wie groß sind die jeweils?
Das heißt, das sind sozusagen in dieser Kurve steckende Informationen.
Man sieht nicht nur, sind schwarze Löcher, sondern man kann quasi zurückrechnen, was da war.
Wie schwer die sind.
Genau.
Man kann den Abstand, also die Entfernung bestimmen, also die kosmologischen Entfernungen.
Man kann bestimmen, wie sich die drehen, also ob sich die beiden schwarzen Löcher
stark drehen oder ob die sich ruhig verhalten.
Und jetzt eben in letzter Zeit, was ganz fantastisch war, man kann auch die
Oberfläche der beiden schwarzen Löcher messen.
Also was Stephen Hawkins hat vorhergesagt, dass wenn sich zwei schwarze Löcher
miteinander vereinigen, dann soll die Oberfläche des neuen schwarzen Loches,
was entsteht, größer sein als die beiden Oberflächen der vorhergehenden Schwarzen Löcher.
Und das konnte man jetzt vor kurzem das erste Mal beweisen. Das war auch fantastisch.
Auch rein aus dieser Gravitationswellen?
Aus der Form des Wellenzuges, ja.
Okay, irre.
Ja.
Genau. Kommen wir doch vielleicht mal so ein bisschen auf diese Detektoren selbst,
die jetzt bisher eingesetzt wurden und die es vor allem seitdem neu gab.
Also alles begann halt mit Geo 600, das ist eben diese Forschungsstation in
der Nähe von Hannover bei Hillesheim, irgendwo so auf dem Feld.
Ich war da ja, also eine unscheinbarere Erscheinung als das geht irgendwie gar nicht.
Also man hat fast das Gefühl, man steht da so ein bisschen im Nichts.
So verloren.
Und dann sind da so ein paar kleine Gebäude und man kommt rein und es ist alles voll mit Technik.
Und ja, es wird einem dann schnell klar so, okay, aber hier ist quasi gerade
eine... Es ist Hightech.
Es ist Hightech, aber es ist halt auch so ein bisschen die Geburtsstätte einer
kompletten neuen Astronomieform.
Und dort wurde die Technik entwickelt, aber man hatte dort nicht den Platz.
Platz hat man immer in Amerika. Finde ich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen...
Schade, merkwürdig, ich habe mich ein bisschen gewundert, wenn das jetzt sozusagen
in Deutschland entwickelt ist, warum gab es da nicht den Push sowas dann auch
gleich in Deutschland aufzubauen oder ist Deutschland einfach generell nicht
mehr geeignet, ob seiner dichten Bebauung für so etwas?
Ja, also man braucht natürlich viel Platz und man braucht sehr,
sehr ruhige Gebiete und das ist halt im Sumpf in Louisiana oder auch an der
Westküste, also Amerika hat halt einfach viel mehr Platz.
Also da wurden die auf jeden Fall gebaut. Das sind also diese beiden LIGOS,
diese L-förmigen Lasermessinstrumente mit der Technik aus Deutschland und die
haben diese erste Detektion gemacht, aber seitdem ist ja einiges passiert.
Mittlerweile gibt es ja noch sehr viel mehr Gravitationsdetektoren.
Genau, also sehr früh gab es dann schon den Virgo-Detektor in der Nähe von Pisa,
also die italienischen Kollegen,
der hat drei Kilometer Kantenlänge und dann kam dazu der Kagra-Detektor in Japan,
der hat also als Besonderheit schon, dass er unter der Erde ist,
der wird also in den Fels geschlagen, weil man eben versuchen möchte,
die Störungen, die auf der Erdoberfläche existieren, halt so gut wie möglich zu reduzieren.
Und es entsteht ein neuer Detektor in Indien.
Das heißt also idealerweise hat man dann ein ganzes Netzwerk von Gravitationsdetektoren.
Sowohl Kagara als auch der indische Detektor sind noch nicht so richtig in Betrieb,
weil Kagara hatte dann Schwierigkeiten mit Wasser,
Problem, Wassereinbruch in dem Tunnel da und das sind halt Herausforderungen,
die ziemlich schwierig sind.
Virgo arbeitet jetzt auch schon die ganze Zeit ganz gut mit,
aber ist leider noch nicht, hat noch nicht so einen großen Schritt in seiner
Empfindlichkeit gemacht wie die beiden LIGO-Detektoren.
Also im Moment ist tatsächlich LIGO führend.
Indigo heißt glaube ich das Ding in Indien?
Genau. Das heißt, es gibt theoretisch, wenn die alle mal so richtig im Betrieb
sind, gibt es zweimal LIGO, dann Indien, Japan und Dings, also fünf Stück, die dann,
also vor allem natürlich erstmal so diese dreidimensionale Ortung eines Signals
nochmal deutlich verbessern dürfen.
Genau, genau.
Gibt es darüber hinaus noch einen Nutzen, dass man so viele hat?
Naja, es ist eben so häufig, also nicht immer, aber es passiert immer wieder
mal, dass einer der Detektoren ausfällt oder einen Glitsch hat.
Also das passiert eben manchmal, dass dann gerade ein Nasswagen vorbeifährt
oder die Stromleitung gerade eingeschaltet wird, während andere ein interessantes Signal sieht.
Und wenn man jetzt drei hat, ist es schon besser und mit fünf ist es noch besser.
Also es ist einerseits Redundanz und andererseits eben die Fähigkeit,
möglichst genau den Ort festzulegen, woher die Quelle kam.
Das heißt, sie sind auch alle fünf unmittelbar miteinander verbunden?
Also unmittelbar insofern, als die sozusagen in diesem International Gravitational
Wave, also Observatory, dann miteinander kooperieren.
Sie sind jetzt nicht physikalisch verbunden miteinander, sondern auch über die Daten.
Ja, klar.
Man muss halt sehr, sehr genau...
Die Zeit auf jedes Ereignis stempeln und dann kann man die miteinander korrelieren
später und kann praktisch die Daten dann,
also später heißt innerhalb von wenigen Minuten werden dann die Informationen
miteinander zusammengelegt, um möglichst gute Lokalisation zu haben.
Wir reden ja von explosiven Ereignissen, also die passieren nur einmal irgendwo
und wenn man das verpasst und spät hingeschaut hat, dann war es das.
Das heißt man muss möglichst schnell reagieren.
Wie kriegen die Zeitsynchronisationen hin?
Ich glaube, auf der Ebene geht es noch mit GPS-Zeiten.
Das sind dann vielleicht Submillisekunden oder sowas.
Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel im Radiobereich diese Antennen miteinander verbindet,
diese Radiointerferometrie, wo man wirklich die Wellensignale einander überlagert,
dann braucht man Atomuhren oder Maser,
die dann sozusagen die Zeit besonders gut festlegen.
Aber das ist ein gelöstes Problem.
Ja.
Und jetzt hat es bei LIGO auf jeden Fall schon ein technisches Upgrade gegeben,
jetzt in diesen letzten zehn Jahren?
Also es gab mehrere Upgrades und was wir jetzt haben, ist das sogenannte Advanced LIGO,
in dem jetzt sozusagen schon die neuesten Detektoren verwendet werden und vor
allem auch eine Technik, die
also auch revolutionär ist, nämlich gequetschtes Licht, squeezed light.
Und zwar Licht ist ja auch ein quantenmechanisches Phänomen und im Rahmen der
Quantenmechanik gibt es eben die Heisenbergsche Unschärferelation,
dass man also nicht alles exakt gleichzeitig messen kann.
Man kann entweder die Geschwindigkeit oder den Ort eines Teilchens messen und
das gilt für die Lichtquelle auch.
Und da gibt es jetzt Techniken,
die sozusagen die quantenmechanische Unsicherheit in einer gewissen Dimension
sozusagen reduzieren, also da wo es einem besonders interessant ist und dafür
aber in der anderen Dimension dann die Unsicherheit,
also man quetscht sozusagen die Fehler des Lichtes zusammen,
sodass man noch genauer messen kann.
Man quetscht das Licht, also den Laser jetzt, den man schickt, den quetscht man?
Also man muss sagen, also nehmen wir mal an, ein Teilchen, also das Licht ist
ja auch, es gibt Lichtquanten und so ein Teilchen hat einen Ort,
also das sind drei Dimensionen und eine Geschwindigkeit, das sind auch nochmal
drei Dimensionen, also es sind sechs Parameter, die sozusagen so ein Teilchen bestimmen.
Und wenn ich die alle sechs Parameter genau messen möchte, dann gibt es eben
diese Heisenbergsche Unschärferelation, die mir immer sagt, ich kann maximal
drei von denen genau messen, die anderen weiß ich dann gar nicht.
Oder ich kann einen Kompromiss schließen und sagen, die Geschwindigkeit ein
bisschen messen und den Ort ein bisschen messen.
Und jetzt gibt es eben dieses sogenannte gequetschte Licht, wo einige Dimensionen
dieser Teilchen besonders genau gemessen werden, dafür die anderen weniger genau,
sodass man sozusagen ein Optimum in der Messgenauigkeit bekommt.
Also man quetscht. Versuche mir gerade vorzustellen, wie man Licht quetscht.
Also das ist eigentlich nicht das Licht selber, was gequetscht wird,
sondern die Unsicherheit, mit der man das Licht messen kann, wird gequetscht.
Unsicherheit wird gequetscht, also es ist eine Eigenschaft des Messgerätes, die sich dort ändert?
Ja, beziehungsweise man muss das Licht sozusagen durch spezielle sogenannte
Filter-Cavities schicken, das hängt dann auch im Prinzip noch davon ab,
das hängt von der Frequenz des Lichtes ab, also man kann das zum Beispiel für
blaues Licht dann gut machen, dann funktioniert es aber im roten Licht nicht
mehr so gut, das heißt, das ist also eine hochkomplexe physikalische Anwendung,
Aber dieses gequetschte Licht,
da ist zum Beispiel die Universität Hannover und das Arbeit-Einstein-Institut
in Hannover sind da weltführend.
Und das ist ein Teil jedes zukünftigen Interferometers.
Und dadurch verbessert sich nochmal die sich letzten Endes abbildende Kurve.
Das heißt, man hat einen feiner aufgelösten Chip.
Man muss dazu sagen, also man versucht ja sozusagen das Wackeln des Weltalls
zu messen und dazu muss man sämtliche anderen Wackelquellen möglichst ausschalten.
Ich rede jetzt mal nicht von LIGO, sondern von der nächsten Generation,
zum Beispiel das Einstein-Teleskop, wo man jetzt schon nochmal eine Stufe besser werden möchte.
Die größte Wackelquelle ist die Erde selber. Also das heißt,
die Erdoberfläche wackelt, weil da eben Autos fahren und Züge.
Und man hat auch die Ozeanwellen, die wackeln und so weiter.
Also jetzt, das versucht man auszuschalten dadurch, dass man eben an einen sehr
ruhigen Standort geht und dann noch besser in die Erde.
Also wenn man in 200 Meter Tiefe geht, dann ist dieses Wackeln der Erde möglichst
schon dramatisch reduziert ein Faktor von 100 bis 1000.
Das ist von Erdbeben mal abgesehen.
Jaja, die Erdbeben kommen von innen. Dann, wenn man das Wackeln sieht,
Wenn der Erde los wird, dann ist die nächstgrößte Wackelquelle der Spiegel selber.
Das heißt also der Laserstrahl wird ja hin und her geschickt zwischen zwei Spiegeln.
Die Oberfläche dieses Spiegels wackelt durch die braunsche Molekularbewegung
der Temperatur der Spiegeloberfläche.
Also Temperatur bedeutet ja Bewegung und jetzt möchte man gerne diese Bewegung
sozusagen reduzieren und dadurch muss man diese Spiegel dann bei kalten Temperaturen betreiben.
Also man muss sie auf 10 Grad über den absoluten Nullpunkt zum Beispiel bringen,
dann wackelt die Oberfläche nicht mehr.
Das wird aber jetzt noch nicht gemacht.
Das wird jetzt erst vorbereitet.
Aber die nächste Idee ist, gekühlte Spiegel zu verwenden.
Und dann kommt ein Faktor dazu, dass nämlich die Laserstrahlen schicken ja Licht.
Und Licht besteht ja eben auch aus Photonen. Das heißt, das Licht ist nicht
kontinuierlich, sondern das wackelt, das ist gebanscht.
Und diese Impulsvariationen, die durch das Licht kommen, die führen dazu,
dass der Spiegel zu wackeln anfängt.
Und deswegen muss man den Spiegel möglichst schwer machen, damit er möglichst nicht so wackelt.
Und dann kommt als nächster Faktor dieses gequetschte Licht,
das heißt also man versucht jetzt das Wackeln in Ausbewegungsrichtung möglichst
klein zu machen und dafür aber quer zur Bewegungsrichtung größer und das ist
eben dann nochmal eine Reduktion des Rauschens.
Das heißt also letztendlich geht es einfach darum, diese Berge von Störquellen
möglichst abzutragen, damit dann das Signal vom Himmel übrig bleibt.
Wie tief ist denn Kagra in Japan, also wenn das das erste Unterirdische ist?
Also Kagra ist in einen Berg eingebaut. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie hoch der Berg ist.
Da geht es mehr um den Schutz durch den Berg, nicht so sehr durch eine absolute Tiefe.
Ja, also einfach damit sozusagen dann die Störungen, die menschengemachten Störungen
von außen etwas geringer sind.
Aber zum Beispiel, wenn wir über das Einstein-Teleskop reden,
dort geht es darum, da 200, 250 Meter Tiefe in schön stabile Gesteinsschichten reinzugehen.
Wenn man Wellen misst, misst man ja Frequenzen?
Und diesen Chirp, den wir da sehen, ist ja quasi auch eine Änderung in dieser Frequenz.
Jetzt ist ja immer das Messen von Frequenzen eben auch abhängig davon,
wie groß ist sozusagen das Messgerät.
Man kennt das ja auch aus dem Audio-Bereich, also man muss eine entsprechende
Auflösung haben, um irgendwie auch noch hohe Frequenzen mitzunehmen.
Oder umgekehrt, ich liebe die Bass-Lautsprecher, die dann so 50 Zentimeter Durchmesser
haben und die schon so richtig Luft schieben.
Sodass man es halt auch spürt. Welche Limitierungen gibt es jetzt sozusagen
durch diese Methode, die man derzeit hat mit dem Laser oder mit diesen Längen der Laser?
Also was kann man denn sehen und was kann man denn vielleicht nicht sehen, was man sehen möchte?
Genau, also durch die Länge des Interferometers gibt es natürlich eine Frequenzlimitierung.
Und dann gibt es aber eben diese Störquellen, zum Beispiel das seismische Rauschen
auf einer Seite oder das Quantenrauschen des Lichtes auf der anderen Seite.
Das sind auch sowieso Wände, die dann irgendwie nicht mehr erlauben, tiefer zu gehen.
Also bei niedrigen Frequenzen, wir reden jetzt da so von ein paar Hertz,
da ist dann plötzlich die Seismik im Weg und bei hohen Frequenzen, ein paar hundert Hertz,
dann kommt dieses Quantenrauschen der Laser dazu.
Und jetzt kann man eben, je nachdem wie man sozusagen sein Messgerät aufbaut,
kann man die Frequenz etwas beeinflussen und vor allem die...
Was jetzt interessant wird, ist, dass man eben versucht zu niedrigeren Frequenzen
zu kommen und niedrigere Frequenzen bedeutet größere Objekte,
also größere Schwarze Löcher.
Also diese ganzen Detektoren laufen also jetzt teilweise seit zehn Jahren.
Wirklich nicht ganz so lang, ich weiß nicht, aber auch schon eine Weile.
Jetzt ist einiges gemessen worden und man hat auch festgestellt,
da kommt jetzt nicht nur so alle Jubiläare mal was, sondern da passiert schon
öfter mal was. Also wie hat sich denn das jetzt eingependelt?
Wie viele Ereignisse, die jetzt wirklich relevant sind und die auf irgendwas
hinweisen, wo man weiß, okay, das ist auch was, kommen denn jetzt tatsächlich?
Also jetzt in dem letzten Beobachtungslauf von Laigo Virgo Cagra, O4,
der wurde insgesamt in drei verschiedene Gruppen unterteilt, O4A,
B, C und C ist jetzt gerade vor ein paar Tagen zu Ende gegangen und in dem letzten
Lauf gab es zweimal pro Woche ungefähr ein Ereignis.
Und Ereignis ist eben dieser Chirp, also wo dann zwei schwarze Löcher sich miteinander vereinigt haben.
Oder auch nicht schwarze Löcher.
Sondern z.B. Neutronenstern. Da kommen wir gleich noch drauf.
Und die Gesamtanzahl von solchen Ereignissen hat sich jetzt auf über 200 erhöht.
Also wir reden jetzt nicht mehr von Einzeldingen, sondern von richtig toller Statistik.
Und das Interessante ist, wenn man jetzt die Massen anschaut,
die da vorkommen, dann sind diese 30 Sonnenmassen, die wir am Anfang wo wir so überrascht waren,
drüber die sind praktisch heute gang und gäbe also die Mehrzahl der LIGO Ereignisse
hat in der Gegend von 30 bis 50 Sonnenmassen.
Gesamtsumme und dann gibt es aber einige Ereignisse die besonders hervorstechen,
also inzwischen hat LIGO Birgokagra auch 100 und 200 Sonnenmassenobjekte gefunden
die man eigentlich kaum erwartet hätte,
Und dann ist es auch so, dass es immer mehr von den leichten Objekten gibt,
die so im Bereich von einer Sonnenmasse liegen,
wo man eigentlich bisher dachte, dass das Neutronensterne sein können,
aber es gibt eben diese Theorie der primordialen schwarzen Löcher,
die vorhersagen, dass es auch eine starke Komponente von primordialen schwarzen
Löchern bei einer Sonnenmasse existiert.
Und vielleicht kommen wir jetzt ganz kurz auf dieses eine Ereignis,
was wirklich auch bahnbrechend war.
1708-17, also am 17. August 2017, ist dieses Neutronensternverschmelzungsereignis,
diese sogenannte Kilonova, passiert.
Und das war wirklich ein Durchbruch.
Weil es das erste Mal war, dass man sozusagen Sound zu den optischen Informationen dazu bekommen hat.
Also wie der Sturmfilm wurde sozusagen in den Tonfilm umgewandelt.
Ich habe das früher Bringing Sound to the Cosmic Movies genannt,
also dass man sozusagen jetzt plötzlich nicht nur sieht, sondern auch hört.
Weil wenn die schwarzen Löcher sich da vereinigen, dann sieht man halt nichts.
Ja, oder nur sehr selten. Wir werden ja vielleicht hinterher noch über Lisa
reden, über dieses große Weltraum-Observatorium.
Lisa wird supermassereiche Schwarze Löcher sehen, die sich miteinander vereinigen.
Und die kommen ja nicht alleine, sondern die kommen immer mit so einem ganzen
Hofstaat von Materie und Sternen und weiß nicht was alles, die sich dann auch
miteinander vereinigen.
Da würde man wahrscheinlich auch wieder elektromagnetische Signale erwarten.
Aber wenn so zwei einsame, arme, schwarze Löcher so von Sternanmassen sich miteinander
vereinigen, dann sieht man da nichts.
So handelsübliche.
Genau, da ist dunkel, aber wenn zwei Neutronensterne aufeinander ballern,
dann ist eine Menge los und das ist schon auch immer mal beobachtet worden,
beziehungsweise man hat halt was beobachtet und nahm an, dass das dann zwei
Neutronensterne waren.
Bei den Gammastrahlenausbrüchen, genau. Also früher gab es schon sozusagen so
Gamma-Bursts, da haben wir auch schon tausende davon gesehen.
Vielleicht nur so ein kleiner Ausflug in die Geschichte, das basierte damals
auf den Atomsperrverträgen, wo also Russland und Amerika beschlossen haben,
keine Atomversuche mehr zu machen im Weltraum.
Und um sich gegenseitig zu kontrollieren, haben sie dann Satelliten hochgeschickt,
die praktisch Gamma-Blitze entdecken können.
Und plötzlich gab es diese Gamma-Blitze und Gott sei Dank ist dann nicht der
Dritte Weltkrieg ausgebrochen, weil sie dann gemerkt haben, die kommen nicht
von der Erde, sondern die kommen von weit her.
Und diese Gamma-Blitze sind dann eine ganz eigene astronomische Industrie geworden.
Und da gibt es zwei Sorten, sehr lange Gamma-Blitze, die so Minuten vielleicht
dauern und sehr kurze, die nur Sekunden oder weniger als die Sekunde dauern.
Und bei diesen kurzen hat man immer schon vermutet, dass es sich dabei um Neutronenstern-Vorgänge
handelt, also um die Vereinigung von zwei Neutronensternen.
Wie man Kilonova nennt.
Genau und dieses Ereignis am 17.08.17,
da hat man sowohl eine Gravitationswelle entdeckt, also diesen Terp und wenige
Sekunden später ein Gammablitz und dann hat man nachgeschaut und konnte tatsächlich
identifizieren die Galaxie,
in der dies passiert ist und dann hat man Wochen und Monate und heute noch sieht
man Signale aus dieser Kilonova-Verschmelzung.
Also dort sind das erste Mal nachweisbar die schweren Elemente entstanden,
zum Beispiel wie Platin und Uran und Thorium und Cäsium und so weiter.
Wo man bisher nicht so richtig verstanden hat, wo die eigentlich herkommen.
Und da wurde dann, also alle Welt hat jetzt gesagt, jetzt haben wir endlich
gesehen, wie Gold entsteht.
Also das Jod in den Blutbahnen und das Gold in den Zähnen, da hat man gedacht,
dass das jetzt sozusagen diese Neutronensternvereinigungen die Grundlage dafür
sind. Das stimmt heute nicht mehr so ganz.
Wir gehen davon aus, dass das Gold nicht so entsteht.
Ach echt?
Aber das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema.
Okay. Davon bin ich jetzt immer ausgegangen.
All die Gewissheit ist schon wieder verflogen.
Nein, es ist so, wir sehen diese schweren, diese sogenannten R-Prozesselemente,
also die mit sehr vielen Neutronensternen reicher Materie entstehen müssen.
Wir sehen die schon sehr, sehr früh im Universum und wir sehen sie auch in Zwerggalaxien,
wo sie, also wenn man eine Neutronenstern-Vereinigung hat, dann muss man ja
zunächst mal zwei Explosionen überleben.
Zwei Sterne müssen explodieren und Neutronensterne bilden.
Das ist schon mal sehr schwierig, wenn man so eine eine Neutronenstern-Explosion
hat, dann wird dieses System schon, kriegt schon eine Kick-Velocity,
also eine Geschwindigkeit und verlässt seine Muttergalaxie.
Und wenn der zweite Stern dann explodiert, dann passiert das nicht mehr in der
Galaxie, sondern irgendwo weiter draußen.
Und dann dauert es noch eine Milliarde Jahre, bis die beiden Neutronensterne
so weit zusammenkommen, dass sie sich miteinander vereinigen.
Das heißt, es ist ein interessantes Phänomen im heutigen Universum,
aber im frühen Universum reicht es nicht aus, also es dauert zu lange,
bis sich diese Neutronensterne miteinander vereinigen.
Deswegen braucht es andere Phänomene und da komme ich vielleicht zum Schluss
nochmal drauf, es gibt jetzt einen ganz, ganz heißen Kandidat,
der auch mit Gravitationswellen zusammenhängt,
wo also das Gold vielleicht erklärt werden kann.
Okay, aber bleiben wir nochmal bei den Messungen, die jetzt konkret stattgefunden
haben in den letzten zehn Jahren.
Also wir haben nicht nur so die herkömmlichen schwarzen Löcher,
sondern auch größere und auch sehr viel kleinere gesehen, die sich irgendwie zusammentun.
Man hat die Neutronensterne und ich glaube auch die Kombination Neutronenstern
und schwarze Löcher lässt sich ja auch nochmal erkennen.
Ja, also es ist so, bisher ist die Betrachtungsweise im Wesentlichen anhand der Massen,
also alles was sozusagen weniger als zwei oder drei Sonnenmassen hat,
wird in diesem Zusammenhang als
Neutronenstern bezeichnet und alles was schwerer ist als schwarzes Loch.
Also man kann es nicht wirklich sehen, man nimmt es nur an.
Man nimmt es an und ich bin ehrlich gesagt der Meinung, dass ein Großteil der
Objekte, die die Leute heute Neutronensterne nennen in dem Zusammenhang,
auch schwarze Löcher sein könnten.
Also das ist eben noch diese Debatte, ob es primordiale schwarze Löcher gibt oder nicht.
Und wenn es die gibt, dann müssten die auch in dieser Klasse von leichten Objekten drin sein.
Okay, aber wie oft, also wir hatten jetzt zweimal pro Woche gibt es so ein Ereignis.
Oder zweimal pro Woche messen wir so ein Ereignis. Vielleicht gibt es die ja
noch sehr viel öfter, man muss nur noch mal ein bisschen genauer hinschauen.
Ja, aber wenn man empfindlichere Detektoren hat, dann passiert das zehnmal am Tag sozusagen.
Also das Einstein-Teleskop zum Beispiel oder Cosmic Explorer,
die nächste Generation, würde so ein Ereignis vielfach, weil man natürlich viel
weiter rausschauen kann.
Und diese Ereignisse finden ja nicht unbedingt in unserer Galaxis statt.
Die sind im ganzen Universum verteilt. Beziehungsweise, wenn man die Entfernungen
anschaut, die jetzt im Moment kommen, dann ist es so immer noch vor unserer kosmischen Haustür.
Aber die Entfernung kann man auch rauslesen?
Die kann man messen, ja. Also das Gravitationssignal gibt einem auch Informationen
über den Abstand des Objekts.
Das ist eben so fantastisch, weil damit kann man im Prinzip,
wenn man viele von denen hat, kann man auch die Hubble-Konstante nochmal neu bestimmen.
Aber das würde doch bedeuten, dass sich das Signal irgendwie ändert,
wenn es länger unterwegs ist, oder woran kann man das sehen?
Ja, also durch die Rotverschiebung wird ja die...
Die Zeit sozusagen verändert.
Ach, die Ausdehnung, okay, na klar, also die Ausdehnung des Universums steckt
da natürlich genauso drin.
Steckt mit drin, ja genau. Also wenn man ein weit entferntes Signal findet,
dann dauert es wesentlich länger als das gleiche Signal in unserer Nähe.
Also die Frequenz wird tiefer sozusagen, aber die Charakteristika sind die gleichen. Ah, okay, gut.
Das heißt, und wie weit konnte man dort schon schauen?
Also ist man dann auch schon so bis ans Ende des beobachtbaren Universums gelangt?
Nee, eben noch nicht. Also das heißt, Also in Rotverschiebungen gerechnet kann
LIGO im Moment maximal ungefähr bis Z gleich 1 messen.
Und Z gleich 1 ist ungefähr die Hälfte des Alters des Universums.
Wofür steht Z in dem Zahnar?
Also Z ist die Rotverschiebung. Z ist 0, ist sozusagen unser lokales Universum.
Und Z gleich 1 heißt, dass man im Prinzip schon ein Signal um einen Faktor 2
sozusagen rot verschoben hat.
Also blaues Licht erscheint dann schon als rot.
Und man misst ja heutzutage, James Webb misst bis Z gleich 15,20 etwa.
Und die Mikrowellen-Hintergrundstrahlung, das Wackeln des Urknalls,
das sieht man bei Z gleich 1100, also 1100.
Da ist die Wellenlänge des Lichtes 1101 mal verschoben.
Und das ist sozusagen das Ende der Beobachtung.
Ja, genau.
Das heißt, da würde man eigentlich ganz gerne mit den Gravitationswellen noch hin.
Oder noch weiter hinaus.
Okay, aber wir sind jetzt bei 1.
Genau, im Moment kommt man zu eins. Sowohl LISA, das Weltraumobservatorium der
ESA, als auch die nächste Generation an bodengebundenen Teleskopen,
also Einstein-Teleskop und Cosmic Explorer,
können bis Z gleich 100 oder 1000 messen. Und das heißt, da kann man dann Objekte sehen,
die wirklich so früh entstanden sind im Universum, dass man dann sagen kann,
ob das primordiale schwarze Löcher sind oder ob man wirklich die erste Generation von Sternen sieht.
Das heißt, dann wäre die Erwartung auch, dass man jetzt nicht zweimal die Woche
eine Messung hat, sondern dann ist eigentlich am laufenden Meter was los.
Zig mal am Tag, ja.
Wow, okay. Wenn man das also mal hochrechnen würde, zig mal am Tag.
Das sind Zehntausende von Objekten, die man da dann sieht.
Pro Tag.
Nein, nein, also insgesamt, also wenn das Ding dann so ein Jahr oder ein paar
Jahre misst, dann rechnen wir wirklich von.
Ich wollte jetzt so ein bisschen darauf hinaus, sagen wir mal,
wir sehen jetzt 100 Ereignisse pro Tag.
Ja.
Was sagt denn das über das Universum aus? Also es knallt, aber jetzt ist ja
so eine Zahl wie 100, ist ja irgendwie nichts in Universumsdimensionen.
Das heißt, wir sehen schon wirklich sehr seltene Ereignisse.
Natürlich, klar. Ich meine, das Universum selbst hat ja, also wir reden von
100 Milliarden Sternen in unserer Milchstraße und 100 Milliarden Galaxien insgesamt.
Also das ist eine Eins mit 22 Nullen und 100 Objekte ist eine Eins mit zwei Nullen.
Also man hat da noch einen 20 Nullen Unterschied.
Aber ich glaube, es gibt zwei Punkte. Das eine ist, natürlich wird die Anzahl
von Objekten größer, aber auch die Signale der schon bekannten Objekte werden
zehnmal besser sozusagen oder hundertmal besser.
Das heißt also, man kann jede einzelne von diesen Wellenformen viel,
viel präziser messen und kann sehr, sehr viel über das Signal lernen.
Also wir haben vorher zum Beispiel darüber gesprochen, man kann Neutronensterne
haben oder schwarze Löcher.
Ein Neutronenstern hat eine harte Oberfläche und das wirkt sich auf die Wellenform aus.
Das heißt also man kann die Verbiegbarkeit der Oberfläche dann dieser Objekte
messen, wenn man ein Signal hat, was hundertmal besser ist als die heutigen Signale.
Und daraus kann man zum Beispiel eindeutig entscheiden, ob man ein schwarzes
Loch hat oder einen Neutronenstern. und man kann sogar die Zustandsgleichung
der Neutronensterne sehr genau messen.
Also was heute noch unbekannt ist, wie groß ist eigentlich so ein Neutronenstern,
Masse- und Radiusbeziehung.
Das kann man daraus ablesen, okay.
Das wird ja, also ich meine, das ist ja dann schon, da kann man schon von einer
signifikanten Verbesserung des Verständnisses des Universums reden, oder?
Sogenannte subsolare Ereignisse, also Ereignisse, deren Masse weniger als eine Sonnenmasse sind.
Also astrophysikalisch entsteht ein Neutronenstern dann, wenn zum Beispiel ein
weißer Zwerg im Zentrum des Sternes dann langsam,
oder ein Eisenkern dann kollabiert und dann ein Neutronenstern daraus entsteht.
Und das ist bei einer sogenannten Chandra-Seca-Masse, also das muss genau bei
1,4 Sonnenmassen passieren.
Und deswegen haben Neutronensterne typischerweise Massen zwischen 1,4 Sonnenmassen
und maximal drei Sonnenmassen.
Und danach werden es dann schwarze Löcher.
Aber es ist hochinteressant, dass es Theorien gibt, die auch kompakte Objekte,
die weniger als eine Sonnenmasse vorhersagen.
Also normalerweise, wenn man weniger als eine Sonnenmasse hat,
hat man automatisch einen weißen Zwerg, der ist dann so groß wie die Erde und
die Neutronensterne sind ja nur so groß wie Berlin oder Dresden.
Und jetzt gibt es die ersten Hinweise auf Signale, die weniger als eine Sonnenmasse
schwer sind und das können zwei Möglichkeiten sein.
Es könnte entweder primordiale schwarze Löcher sein, also die können nämlich
auch wesentlich kleiner sein.
Was heißt primordial in dem Zusammenhang?
Die dann sozusagen nicht durch den Kollaps eines Sternes entstanden sind,
sondern im frühen Universum durch Massekonzentrationen, die am eigenen Gewicht
schon nach wenigen Sekunden zusammenstürzen.
Also die sehr früh schon unabhängig von Sternen.
Und diese primordialen schwarzen Löcher könnten im Prinzip auch die dunkle Materie darstellen.
Also die dunkle Materie ist ja immer noch nicht bekannt, die Leute suchen seit
Generationen nach diesem Teilchen und jetzt stellt sich plötzlich heraus,
dass vielleicht primordiale schwarze Löcher ein Teilchen,
Also die dunkle Materie sein könnten. Aber wenn es so wäre, dann sagt die Theorie
eindeutig vorher, dass es auch schwarze Löcher geben soll, die weniger als eine Sonnenmasse haben.
Und da gibt es jetzt die allerersten, noch nicht hundertprozentig sicheren Signale,
aber in den letzten Wochen gab es zwei Ereignisse, die hochspannend waren,
wo man von LIGO gesehen hat, dass es dort Signale gibt, die sich mit 0,1 bis
0,5 Sonnenmassen miteinander vereinigt haben.
Also alle Annahmen bisher von schwarzen Löchern, dass das immer so riesige Ereignisse
sind und Zentrum der Galaxis und das saugt irgendwie alles auf,
das stimmt, aber könnte auch welche sein.
Es könnte sogar welche, die Asteroidenmassen haben und planetare Massen.
Also es könnte sein, dass unser Sonnensystem voll von kleinen schwarzen Löchern
ist, die wir noch nicht gesehen haben.
Dunkle Materie taucht ja immer wieder fast in jeder Sendung auf,
aber kann man nicht müde betonen.
Das ist sozusagen the biggest unknown derzeit. Man weiß, es gibt sehr viel mehr Masse.
Man kann es einfach ableiten aus der Beobachtung der Galaxien,
die sich sonst einfach nicht so drehen könnten, wie sie es eben tun.
Nur man sieht halt nichts. Und dieses Nicht-Sehen ist halt sozusagen die große
Frage, was ist es, was wir nicht sehen?
Ist es etwas, was wirklich im eigentlichen Sinne dunkel ist,
wie der Name ja jetzt hier irgendwie insinuiert, dass es sozusagen nur einfach kein Licht aussendet.
Da sind natürlich schwarze Löcher sozusagen einfach, indem sie einfach das Licht
bei sich behalten, auch wenn es das theoretisch in ihnen natürlich gibt.
Oder eben so die andere Theorie, der ja genauso nachgegangen wird beim Zerren etc.
Ob es Teilchen sind. Teilchenphysik ist, dass man einfach weiß,
okay es gibt da noch irgendein Teilchen, das einfach eine Masse hat.
Aber aus welchen Gründen auch immer, nicht im elektromagnetischen Spektrum sich
in irgendeiner Form abbildet.
Genau, und das ist so ein bisschen noch offen, bleibt wahrscheinlich auch noch eine Weile offen.
Also wir haben ja ein Teilchen der dunklen Materie schon gefunden, das ist das Neutrino.
Das Neutrino sollte ja eigentlich nach der klassischen Theorie keine Masse haben,
aber inzwischen hat man ja festgestellt, dass Neutrinos Masse haben.
Ach doch.
Ganz, ganz kleine Massen, aber im Prinzip ist das Neutrino schon ein Teilchen,
was genau die Eigenschaften der dunklen Materie widerspiegelt.
Aber das Neutrino ist so leicht, dass es sich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegt und das ist zu schnell.
Also wir brauchen sogenannte kalte dunkle Materie und das Neutrino ist heiße dunkle Materie.
Na, Teufel auch.
Ja, wir kommen auch gleich nochmal zu den Multi-Messenger-Geschichten,
wo ja die Gravitationsfolgen eine große Rolle spielen, aber die Neutrinos ja auch.
Jetzt haben wir geschaut, okay,
was ist bisher an Detektoren gebaut worden, wie haben die funktioniert,
da haben wir im Prinzip ja eine Funktionsweise jetzt beschrieben,
die jetzt konkret implementiert wurde.
Wir sehen jetzt auch, was wurde davon detektiert und es gibt den Ausblick, okay,
man kann diese Technik noch verbessern und es ist absehbar, dass allein die
Verbesserung dieser Technik schon eine ganze Menge bringen wird.
Aber jetzt gibt es ja auch noch andere Ansätze, die wir hier haben.
Für Detektoren noch mal Messungen in irgendeiner Form vorzunehmen.
Was steht da sozusagen auf der Liste?
Also wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, dass die Gravitationswellen eine Art Spektrum auch darstellen.
Also wenn wir mal kurz auf das elektromagnetische Spektrum kommen,
das ist ja eigentlich ein Riesenbereich zwischen Radio- und Gamma-Strahlen.
Man hat ungefähr 56 Oktaven, die dieses Spektrum beschreiben.
Ein großes Piano hat acht Oktaven, das heißt man muss also acht große Pianos
nebeneinander stellen und jede Seite muss anders gespannt sein,
dann kriegt man sozusagen das gesamte elektromagnetische Spektrum dargestellt.
Beim Gravitationswellenspektrum ist es so ähnlich, das sind zwar nicht so viele
Dimensionen, aber trotzdem gibt es sehr große Unterschiede zwischen dem,
was man jetzt terrestrisch messen kann,
und Signalen, die noch viel, viel länger wellig sind.
Und der nächste Schritt ist, dass die ESA im Moment dieses LISA-Projekt baut.
Da spielt übrigens auch Hannover eine große Rolle. Also die deutsche Koordination
von dem LISA-Projekt findet im Albert-Einstein-Institut in Hannover statt.
Dort handelt es sich um ein Dreieck aus Satelliten, die hinter der Erde herfliegen
um die Sonne und einen 2,5 Millionen Kilometer Abstand haben.
Also hinter der Erde hinterherfliegen, also ich nehme an, das ist Lagrange-Punkt.
Nee, das ist nicht Lagrange-Punkt, sondern jeder einzelne Satellit fliegt sozusagen
um die Sonne in einer Bahn, die 60 Millionen Kilometer von der Erde entfernt ist.
Also man kann sich vorstellen, die Erde fliegt um die Sonne und hinten dran
gibt es dann so ein Dreieck von Satelliten, die auch um die Sonne fliegen.
Hinten dran, also ein Dreieck, was der Erde folgt, aber nicht an einem Lagrange-Punkt.
Nein, genau. Das wird in den Sonnenorbit gebracht,
in dem auch die Erde sitzt. Und jeder einzelne Satellit hat seine eigene Umlaufbahn um die Sonne.
Und diese Umlaufbahnen sind ganz klein wenig gekippt gegenüber der Erde.
Und wenn man dann die drei Satelliten genau richtig hinbringt,
dann fliegt jeder unabhängig voneinander um die Sonne, aber sie drehen sich
dann in so einem gleichschenklichen Dreieck umeinander herum mit zweieinhalb
Millionen Kilometer Kantenlänge.
Und jetzt ist es so, wir haben ja vorher gesprochen von diesem Michelson-Interferometer,
wo sozusagen derselbe Laserstrahl hergenommen wird und in sich selbst sozusagen
wieder interferiert wird.
Dazu muss man praktisch sicherstellen, dass man den gleichen Wellenberg immer
und das gleiche Wellental findet.
Das heißt, die Abstände dieser Laserstrahlen müssen also auf weniger als Zignanometer
oder sowas, also auf einen Bruchteil der optischen Wellenlänge genau festgelegt werden.
Also wir reden jetzt von einem Laserstrahl, der zwischen diesen drei Satelliten ein Dreieck aufspannt.
Ja, also ich wollte jetzt nochmal kurz zurück auf das Standardverfahren, was LIGO verwendet.
Das ist ein Michelson-Interferometer, wo ein Laserstrahl aufgespalten wird in
zwei Teile und dann wieder in sich zurückreflektiert wird und dann muss man
sicherstellen, dass man sozusagen auf demselben Wellenberg landet,
wieder in beiden Strahlen.
Das ist keine Phasenverschiebung.
Genau, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel das Interferometer ein kleines Stückchen,
dem einen Fußtritt geben würde, dann sind die Wellen so weit auseinander,
dass man sie gar nicht mehr vermessen kann.
Bei LISA ist es so, dass die Satelliten untereinander jeweils einen Laserstrahl
hin und her schicken, dass aber der Abstand dieser Satelliten um Kilometer sozusagen unbekannt ist.
Also man kann das jetzt nicht auf Nanometer genau regulieren,
sondern man muss sozusagen, das ist kein Michelson-Interferometer,
sondern das ist eine andere Art von Interferometer,
man muss jetzt sozusagen die Wellenlänge mit sich selbst interferieren lassen,
man hat also Wellentäler und Wellenberge, aber die absolute Referenz dieser
Wellen sind nicht mehr bekannt.
Das heißt also, man misst nur noch relativ zueinander.
Man sieht das immer noch, wenn sich der Abstand um ein kleines Stückchen verändert,
aber man kann das nicht jetzt so genau messen, wie wenn man denselben Wellenberg sozusagen hätte.
Trotzdem ist es so, dass man mit Lisa mit diesen zweieinhalb Millionen Kilometern
unheimlich hohe Empfindlichkeiten bekommt.
Und man hat diese ganzen Störstrahlungen von der Erde und sonst was, kein Wackeln, nichts.
Das heißt also, man geht davon aus, dass die Signale, die Lisa sehen wird,
also praktisch absolut starke Signale sind. Da ist überhaupt kein Weg.
Das heißt, funktioniert Lisa im Prinzip genauso wie so ein Distanzlasermessgebiet?
Im Prinzip ja, kann man fast sagen. Wobei dann eben, also innerhalb jedes dieser
Satelliten gibt es freifliegende Massen.
Da hat es ja auch schon das LISA Pathfinder Projekt gegeben,
wo die mit hoher Präzision zeigen konnten, dass das Prinzip funktioniert.
Und Lisa wird jetzt eben im Gegensatz zu LIGO Objekte sehen können,
die so zwischen 100.000 und ein paar Millionen Sonnenmassen sind.
Also das heißt, diese supermassereichen schwarzen Löcher, die ja in allen Galaxien sich befinden.
Wenn sich dort zwei Galaxien miteinander vereinigen, dann wird Lisa dieses Signal sehen.
Das heißt, Lisa misst auch einen ganz anderen Frequenzbereich in diesem Spektrum.
Genau, also sehr, sehr langwellige Frequenzen, also im Bereich von Millihertz
bis Mikrohertz oder irgendetwas.
Und bedeutet das vor allem, dass man weiterschauen kann, weil man sozusagen
mehr Rotverschiebung nimmt?
Nicht unbedingt, sondern vor allem sieht man sehr, sehr massereiche Objekte.
Also andere Ereignisse.
Andere Ereignisse. Lisa kann zum Beispiel diese sogenannten kompakten Binärsysteme
sehen, also Systeme, die aus zwei weißen Zwergen bestehen und die sich einander umkreisen.
Da gibt es jetzt so Doppelsternsysteme, die nur Minuten Orbits haben und die
würden bei LISA praktisch einen sehr starken Hintergrund erzeugen.
Das gibt es überall in der Milchstraße, überall im ganzen Kosmos erzeugen die
so ein generelles Brummen, was überall immer zu sehen ist.
Und darüber überlagert sind dann diese supermassereichen schwarzen Löcher,
die sich miteinander vereinigen,
wo alles das, was wir vorher gesagt haben, dieses Chirpen, eine Million mal
langsamer abläuft etwa.
Millionen Mal, okay. Und was verspricht man sich jetzt primär davon zu entdecken?
Genau, also bei LISA ist es so, dass man vor allem lernen möchte,
woher kommen diese supermassereichen schwarzen Löcher in den Galaxien.
Wir sehen ja praktisch fast in jeder größeren, jeder ordentlichen Galaxie im
Zentrum ein schwarzes Loch.
Unsere eigene Milchstraße hat vier Millionen Sonnenmassen.
Im Andromedanebel sind es vielleicht zehn, zwanzig Millionen Sonnenmassen und
diese größten Galaxien im Universum haben bis zu Milliarden Sonnenmassen schweren schwarzen Löcher.
Und wenn sich dann, wir sehen auch immer wieder solche Galaxienvereinigungsprozesse
im Kosmos, wo zwei Galaxien sich miteinander verheiraten oder sich gegenseitig
auffressen und es muss im Prinzip dann auch,
diese schwarzen Löcher in den Galaxien müssen sich dann auch miteinander vereinigen
und das ist hochspannend.
Weil man da also alle mögliche Astrophysik und Dynamik und sonst was sieht.
Vor allem auch deswegen, weil man diese aktiven schwarzen Löcher,
die im Zentrum von Galaxien sitzen, die strahlen ja sehr hell und das sind die
Quasare zum Beispiel, die also besonders leuchtkräftig sind.
Man geht davon aus, dass solche schwarzen Löcher besonders gut gefüttert werden,
wenn sich zwei Galaxien miteinander vereinigen, weil dann plötzlich im Zentrum
ganz viele Gasströme sozusagen ins Zentrum geschoben werden und die schwarzen
Löcher, die also Milliarden Jahre lang hungern,
kriegen dann plötzlich was zu fressen und strahlen ganz hell.
Und das ist also besonders der Vergleich der elektromagnetischen mit der Gravitationswellensignale
ist also unheimlich spannend, weil man dann genau messen kann, was da passiert.
Man geht zum Beispiel davon aus, dass wenn so ein schwarzes Loch sehr,
sehr gut gefüttert wird, dann strahlt es auch sehr viel ab.
Das heißt also, da gibt es diese Jets, die dann rauskommen und dann so ein schwarzes
Loch ist in der Lage, seine Umgebung freizupusten sozusagen von Materie.
Die neuesten Modelle sagen, dass also am Anfang, wenn sich zwei solche schwarzen
Löcher nähern, sind die sehr helle Röntgenquellen,
man kann sie ziemlich hell sehen und die fangen dann langsam an Gravitationswellen
auszustrahlen, aber wenn sie dann anfangen Gravitationswellen auszustrahlen,
dann pusten sie gleichzeitig ihre
Umgebung frei und dann muss die Röntgenstrahlung erstmal verschwinden.
Und wenn sie sich dann miteinander vereinigen, dann wackelt es und dann gibt
es ein großes neues Objekt und dann dauert es ein paar Monate,
vielleicht bis Jahre, bis dann die Materie wieder reinkommt und dann wieder
sozusagen gefressen wird.
Das heißt, es gibt so einen richtig schönen Tanz zwischen elektromagnetischer
und gravitationswellen Strahlung,
wo man unheimlich viel über die Physik lernt von solchen Schwarzen.
Und das bedeutet auch, dass man jetzt nicht nur so einen kurzen Event hat und
dann war es das, sondern man beobachtet im Prinzip zwei Galaxien dabei,
wie sie sich miteinander vereinigen über einen Zeitraum von Wochen,
Monaten oder Jahren vielleicht sogar.
Also es geht los mit hunderten von Millionen Jahren, wenn man sozusagen sieht,
wie sie sich dann schon annähern, aber da haben wir nicht genügend Zeit,
aber man sieht die letzten Minuten.
Also quasi den Moment der Vereinigung eben flagrant, die ertappt.
Und das würde sich dann über was für einen Zeitraum vielleicht in etwa abbilden?
Also wie gesagt, dieses mit dem Leerpusten, also dass sozusagen irgendwann mal
die Gravitationswellen überwiegen und den Rest der Materie erstmal nach außen
pusten, das ist eine Frage von vielleicht Wochen oder so etwas.
Aber wann würde man das erste Mal was messen können, vermutlich mit Lisa,
wenn das jetzt so im Raum ist?
Das ist im Bereich von Wochen, also so ein Ereignis kann ein ganzes Jahr lang
dauern sozusagen mit Lisa, wenn man Glück hat.
Das heißt also, wenn man die Lokation am Himmel gut genug bestimmen kann,
dann kann man also alle Teleskope darauf richten und insbesondere die Rankenteleskope
können das dann verfolgen.
Dann hat man richtig ein Jahr lang Spaß mit der Vereinigung von zwei Galaxien.
Ein beeindruckendes Projekt, Lisa. Gibt es da noch was?
Ja, also was ich noch sagen wollte, so ähnlich wie auch dein Einstein-Teleskop später,
kann LISA eben bis viel weiter hinausschauen, also praktisch bis an den Rand
des sichtbaren Universums, bis zu einer Rotverschiebung von 1000 etwa,
das ist da, wo der mikrowellen Hintergrund dann beginnt.
Und das kann halt besonders diese sogenannten dunklen Zeiten beurteilen,
wo man eigentlich nichts erwartet, aber wenn Lisa in diesen dunklen Zeiten schwarze Löcher findet,
dann kann man beweisen, dass die primordial sein müssen, also dass sie praktisch
schon von Anfang an da gewesen sind.
So, ja, Lisa, Start ist glaube ich 2035, also da müssen wir noch ein bisschen warten.
Ich glaube, die Eigenschaft eines Weltraumforsches ist erstmal Geduld zu haben.
Ja, das geht ja generell in diesem Segment, das stimmt.
Jetzt gibt es ja auch noch ein paar andere Ansätze, den Gravitationswellen auf
die Spur zu kommen, jenseits der jetzt bereits vorgestellten Techniken und der
von dieser angestrebten Methode. Was gibt es denn da noch?
Genau, also es gibt noch drei verschiedene Themen. Das eine sind die sogenannten Pulsar Timing Arrays.
Das hat sich jetzt gerade im letzten Jahr fantastisch ergeben,
dass also drei oder vier weltweite Kollaborationen ein Signal gefunden haben,
was sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich von einem Gravitationswellenhintergrund stammt.
Und zwar muss man sich das vorstellen, die Pulsare, das sind ja diese Neutronenstern,
die sich unheimlich schnell um ihre eigene Achse drehen.
Wir reden von Millisekunden-Pulsaren, also das sind so 10 Kilometer oder 20
Kilometer große Neutronenbälle, die sich einmal in der Millisekunde um ihre
eigene Achse drehen, also gigantische Unvorstellungen.
Und diese Millisekunden-Pulsare sind eigentlich unheimlich präzise Uhren.
Die werden zum Teil auch benutzt, um die Atomzeit auf der Erde nachzustellen.
Also die Atomuhren sind ja schon fantastisch, aber die gehen weniger genau als
die Millisekundenpulsare.
Das heißt also Millisekundenpulsare insgesamt stellen also eine extrem gute Zeitbasis dar.
Und wenn jetzt eine Gravitationswelle durch unsere Galaxie läuft.
Dann führt die dazu, dass die Uhrzeiten auf der einen Seite alle ein bisschen
nachgehen und auf der anderen Seite ein bisschen schneller laufen.
Also die Gravitationswelle ist ja sozusagen auch eine Verzerrung des Raum-Zeit-Kontinuums
und die Uhren laufen dann auf der einen Seite ein bisschen langsamer und auf
der anderen Seite ein bisschen schneller.
Oder man kann es auch so sehen, die ganzen Millisekunden-Pulsare auf der einen
Seite werden so zehn Meter auf
die eine Seite gerückt und auf der anderen Seite in die andere Richtung.
Und man kann also praktisch die ganze Galaxie als Detektor benutzen,
um extrem langwellige Gravitationswellen zu finden.
Und die werden von Objekten ausgesandt, die so Millionen bis Milliarden Sonnenmassen schwer sind.
Also wenn man dann so richtig dicke Klopper von Galaxien hat,
die sich dann miteinander vereinigen, dann wackelt das Raumzeitkontinuum auf
galaktischen Maßstäben.
Und wenn wir jetzt also typischerweise haben diese Pulsar Timing Arrays,
so eine Zahl von 20, 30 Neutronensternen, die sie gleichzeitig beobachten und
man kann zwar noch nicht, man konnte noch nicht ein einzelnes Ereignis sehen,
also dass dann sozusagen auf der einen Seite alle in eine Richtung ging und
auf der anderen in die andere,
aber man konnte insgesamt an dem Rauschen der Signale schon sehen,
dass da ein Gravitationswellenuntergrund drunter,
Und in Zukunft ist es so, dass wir durch neue Radioteleskope,
da kommen wir dann vielleicht hinterher auf das Querkilometer Array oder auf
das DSA 2000, jetzt vielfach mehr noch neue Neutronensterne entdecken können.
Und wenn man die, sagen wir mal so zehn Jahre lang beobachtet,
dann gehen wir davon aus, dass wir auch in Pulsar Timing Arrays zukünftig einzelne
Ereignisse sehen können.
Also dass man wirklich das zuordnen kann, dass da zwei supermassereiche schwarze
Löcher sich miteinander vereinigen.
Um nochmal zu verstehen, also mit Pulsar Timing Array meint man im Prinzip die
parallele Beobachtung mehrerer bekannter Pulsare mit was für einem Instrument?
Mit Radioteleskopen.
Okay, was man ohnehin schon seit langer Zeit tut, aber dadurch,
dass man sie sozusagen im Konzert anschaut und man weiß, okay,
der feuert mit der Frequenz, der feuert mit der Frequenz, detektiert man im
Prinzip dann in dem Moment, wo eine Gravitationswelle durchläuft,
eine Veränderung bei den einen und die anderen halt noch nicht,
aber die dann später und dann die anderen nicht mehr.
Ja, oder die eine in die eine Richtung und die andere in die andere Richtung.
Also man sieht so richtig, wie die Gravitationswelle durch die Galaxie schwappt.
Also man könnte sich vorstellen, die Gravitationswelle kommt und bewegt sozusagen
alle Pulsare ein Stückchen in eine Richtung.
Und in der Richtung, wo sie auf uns zuläuft, fliegen die Pulsare auf uns zu
und in der Richtung, wo sie von uns wegläuft, von uns weg.
Das heißt, an der einen Seite sind sie rot verschoben und an der anderen Seite blau verschoben.
Und das erzeugt dann ein Signal.
Und das...
Das ist sozusagen jetzt schon über die Jahrzehnte passiert.
Also es haben sich immer mehr Leute, immer mehr Pulsare angeschaut und es gab
eben letztes Jahr mehrere große Publikationen, wo also das Nanograph in den USA,
das European Pulsar Timing Array, das indische Pulsar Timing Array,
also alle Signale gefunden haben.
Und was jetzt eigentlich noch fehlt, ist, dass man diese weltweiten Informationen
alle zu einer Analyse zusammenschmeißt.
Dann wird man nochmal eine höhere Genauigkeit erhalten.
Aber wenn man so im Ausblick schaut, es kommen jetzt eben diese großen Projekte
auf uns zu, neue Radioteleskope, die viel, viel mehr Pulsare noch entdecken werden.
Und das wird also eine ganz, ganz spannende Geschichte.
Wenn man einfach nochmal eine ganz andere Auflösung bekommt.
Genau, also wir reden dann vielleicht von 100 Pulsaren und nicht von 20.
Und auch die Häufigkeit, mit der die beobachtet werden, wird häufiger sein.
Wir sind zum Beispiel an einem Projekt, wollen wir uns beteiligen,
das nennt sich DSA 2000, wo jede Nacht ein ganzes Bild vom ganzen Himmel,
also da wird sozusagen eine Art Video des Himmels, Radio-Video gedreht.
Und da stecken natürlich auch zig neue Pulsare
drin, die dann für solche Pulsar-Timing-Messungen verhandelt werden.
A2000, Deep Synoptic Array, also ein tiefer holistischer Blick auf das ganze Universum.
Jetzt frage ich mich gerade, ist diese Erkennung von Gravitationswellen über diese Pulsare,
Fand das schon vor LIGO statt? Also war das quasi schon so, das muss man ja
auch schon vorher beobachtet haben.
Genau, also das allererste Gravitationswellensignal, da gab es auch den Nobelpreis
dafür schon in den 70er Jahren, das ist der sogenannte Hulse-Taylor-Pulsar.
Das ist also ein System aus zwei Pulsaren, aus zwei Neutronensternen,
die sich einander umkreisen, wovon einer ein sichtbarer Pulsar war.
Und da hat man tatsächlich gesehen, wie sich der Orbit langsam verändert,
also wie die Neutronensterne sich immer näher kommen und das war der Beweis,
so wie es Einstein vorhergesagt hat, dass also Gravitationswellen abgestrahlt werden.
Da konnte man zwar die einzelne Welle nicht sehen, aber man konnte den Effekt
sozusagen sehen. Und das war das erste Mal das hochpräzise Beweis,
Gravitationswellen gefunden wurden, noch vor LIGO.
Aber man hatte nicht jetzt diesen Chirp sozusagen in dieser Information,
aus dem man viel hätte herauslesen können.
Nein, also was man gesehen hat, ist ein Doppelsternsystem, was sich langsam
immer sozusagen immer einander annähert.
Also die Frequenz verändert sich.
Aber den Chirp selber, da muss man noch vielleicht noch paar hunderttausend
bis Millionen Jahre warten, bis der passiert.
Aber wie fein kann jetzt mit so einem Timing Array die Messung werden.
Also wenn ich jetzt so viele Neutronensterne sehe, beobachte und die Zeit vergleiche
und das mit einer hohen Auflösung mache, wie viel Information über das Ereignis
lässt sich daraus lesen?
Also im Moment haben wir so in der Gegend von 20 Pulsaren, die vielleicht so
maximal 10 Jahre lang beobachtet worden sind, aber nicht alle immer gleichzeitig
und nicht alle immer sozusagen mit hoher Kadenz.
Und die Zukunft gibt da zwei Sachen. Das eine ist, dass man wesentlich mehr
kriegt, also dass wir vielleicht von 100 Pulsaren reden, fünfmal mehr,
dass die aber auch viel regelmäßiger beobachtet werden.
Das heißt, die Matrix wird immer voller, das Gitter wird besser gefüllt.
Und die Hoffnung ist, dass wir schon in den nächsten paar Jahren vielleicht
tatsächlich einzelne Ereignisse sehen werden können.
Also bisher sieht man sozusagen nur so das allgemeine Rauschen, so wie der Wind.
Man weiß, dass er da ist, aber man sieht noch nicht aus welcher Richtung er
kommt und da hoffen wir, dass sozusagen im nächsten Schritt wir tatsächlich
einzelne Objekte dann identifizieren können.
Jetzt gibt es glaube ich auch noch so diese Theorie oder vielleicht ist das
ja auch schon sichtbar geworden,
dass so ähnlich wie man das bei der Hintergrundstrahlung des Universums hat,
die auch schon gut gemessen wurde,
die ja im Wesentlichen so die thermische Verteilung nach dem theoretischen Urknall festgehalten hat,
dass quasi all diese Ereignisse bei
der Ausdehnung des Weltalls auch Gravitationswellen quasi erzeugt haben,
die sich vielleicht auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise manifestieren und messbar sind.
Genau, also die sogenannte Mikrowellenhintergrundstrahlung ist ja ungefähr 380.000
Jahre nach dem Urknall entstanden,
zu einer Zeit, als das Universum ungefähr so heiß war wie unsere Sonne,
also so wie die Sonnenoberfläche, ungefähr 3000 Grad heiß.
In dem Moment sind die Atome entstanden, also da haben sich Elektronen und Protonen
miteinander vereinigt und dadurch ist das Universum erstmal kalt genug.
Genau, da war es kalt genug und dass das Universum durchsichtig wurde.
Das kann man so vergleichen mit einer Kerzenflamme, wenn man die Kerzenflamme
anschaut, da wo man das helle Licht sieht, das ist ein Plasma,
wo die Elektronen noch frei sind und dann,
wenn die Kerzenflamme kühler wird, dann werden die Atome gebildet und dann hat
man immer noch heißes Gas.
Also da verbrennt man sich immer noch dran, aber man sieht es nicht mehr.
Das wird dann sozusagen durchsichtig. Und genau in dieser Grenze,
das war 380.000 Jahre nach dem Urknall, ist diese Mikrowellenhintergrundstrahlung entstanden.
Das Licht ist seitdem, hat sich tausendmal ausgedehnt. Also die Frequenz war
vorher sozusagen so heiß wie die Sonne und heute ist es nur noch drei Grad über
dem absoluten Nullpunkt.
Weiter hinein kann man nicht schauen, weil dann hat man sozusagen wie bei der
Sonnenoberfläche auch ein dichtes Medium und kann nicht mehr sozusagen durch
die Sonnenoberfläche durchschauen.
Aber bei der Sonne gibt es ja auch einen Trick. Man kann zum Beispiel die seismischen
Störungen der Sonne, also die Sonne wackelt und man kann Helioseismologie machen.
Man kann also innere akustische Schwingungen sozusagen in diesem Feuerball sehen,
indem man das Wackeln der Oberfläche sozusagen studiert. Und so ähnlich kann
man sich das auch vorstellen.
Also man möchte jetzt gerne Signale finden, die noch früher als 380.000 Jahre entstanden sind.
Zum Beispiel gleich die ersten zwei Sekunden, wo die Hölle los war.
Also der Knall selbst sozusagen.
Dass man quasi das Echo dieses Knalls direkt sehen möchte.
Und das kann man tatsächlich, wenn man Glück hat, kann man das in der Polarisation
des Mikrowellenhintergrundes sehen.
Das heißt also, diese Gravitationswellen verändern den Mikrowellenhintergrund
in einer Weise, dass sie verschiedene Polarisationsmodi anregen.
Sogenannte B-Modes, also B-Moden in der Polarisation,
Und wenn man jetzt, also die Mikrowellenhintergrundstrahlung ist ja sehr,
sehr genau vermessen worden durch Planck, durch WMAP vorher,
durch COBE, aber die Polarisation ist noch nicht so gut vermessen.
Also wenn man die Polarisation des Mikrowellenhintergrundes jetzt messen würde,
dann könnte man auf Gravitationswellen schließen, die wirklich im allerfrühsten
Universum entstanden sind.
Ah, heißt das, man bräuchte nochmal so eine Planck 2 Mission?
Ja, beziehungsweise es gibt jetzt heute schon Projekte, die vor allem am Südpol
messen, wo man also jetzt bodengebunden versucht, die Präzision hochzutreten.
Also man bräuchte ein Planck-artiges Teleskop, aber eigentlich mit viel größerem
Spiegel noch. Das kriegt man so leicht nicht in den Weltraum.
Aber am Südpol entstehen im Moment Projekte, die sowas messen können.
Würde jetzt die Dimension von dem James-Webb-Teleskop da schon ausreichen oder
müsste es noch krasser sein?
Würde im Prinzip gehen, aber es muss halt das Problem, James-Webb ist ja schon
relativ kalt, also ist bei minus 80 Grad oder irgendwie sowas.
Und diese Messungen müssen bei weniger als einem Mikrokelvin stattfinden.
Also da muss der Detektor so stark gekühlt werden, das kriegt man im Weltall nicht so leicht hin.
Also wenn man ein riesiges Teleskop sozusagen so kalt machen möchte,
dazu bräuchte man einen riesen Kühlschrank, ein Gefriergerät.
Im Moment, James Webb ist deswegen so kalt, weil es halt den kalten Weltraum
sieht, aber es wird ja durch den Weltraum gekühlt und man möchte jetzt eigentlich die Dinge,
messen, also man möchte die Strahlung nicht zur Kühlung verwenden,
sondern man muss noch kälter werden als die Strahlung, damit man sie messt.
Also bräuchte man eine richtig große Wärmepumpe Ja,
Also ist es dann, ja, ich meine, wie kommt man denn dann ran an diese Gravitationswellen,
Hintergrundstrahlung? Gibt es da überhaupt einen Ansatz?
Ja, wie gesagt, also im Moment gibt es sozusagen Projekte, die am Südpol entstehen.
Also da ist es sowieso schon kalt und das Teleskop muss dann auch noch gekühlt.
Nein, der Detektor selber muss dann so kalt sein.
Also es gibt ja, diese Polometer, diese empfindlichen Messgeräte werden ja auf
solche Temperaturen abgekühlt.
Also Mini-Calvin oder wenige.
Also Hintergrundstrahlung des Universums, Messen am Südpol, wo es ja auch schön dunkel ist.
Und schön kalt.
Und schön kalt, um dann die Polarisation dieses Lichts zu messen,
um daraus unter Umständen Gravitationswellen ablesen zu können.
Okay, aber mit LISA und so weiter, das reicht sozusagen nicht aus.
Genau, also mit LISA kommt man ungefähr bis Z gleich 1000, also bis ungefähr,
wo die Mikrowellenhintergrundstahlung entstanden ist.
Und mit diesen Methoden würde man bis Z gleich 100.000 oder sowas kommen, also noch viel früher.
Und so eine Super-LISA, wo die drei Satelliten noch weiter auseinander sind,
wird es da auch nicht bringen?
Nein, das Laser ist da schon das Optimum, weil je weiter die Satelliten auseinander
sind, desto stärkeren Laser braucht man und dann wird wiederum das Lasersignal selber das Problem.
Tja, ganz schön kompliziert, Raumfahrttechnik.
Ja, das tolle Wort, was jetzt in den letzten zehn Jahren die Wissenschaftswelt
hier bereichert, ist Multimessenger-Astronomie, wie schon vorhin erwähnt.
Also bisher war immer alles Elektromagnetismus, dann kamen die Gravitationswellen
dazu, dann gibt es so Projekte wie der Ice Cube, wurde ja auch schon besprochen.
In der Antarktis der dicke Würfel im Eis,
wo man eben die Neutrinos misst und durch diese Platzierung auch weiß,
okay, das sind jetzt hier nicht die Fake-Neutrinos, die jetzt hier gerade in
der Atmosphäre gebildet wurden,
dadurch, dass da die kosmische Strahlung aufschlägt, sondern das sind schon
so die Neutrinos von irgendwelchen anderen Ereignissen, die es einmal durch
die Erde geschafft haben.
Und dann kann man dann halt durch diese sekundären Blitzeffekte diese Neutrinos
messen, die ja normalerweise sich aus allem ganz gut raushalten.
Das sind also alles andere Botschafter, die wir auf einmal haben.
Daher kommt der Name Multimessenger-Astronomie, weil man eben jetzt Ereignisse
beobachten kann, eben nicht nur auf eine Art, sondern auf mindestens drei und
ich weiß gar nicht, ob es jetzt noch weitere gibt, die jetzt hier in der Reihe stehen.
Das ist natürlich jetzt auch erstmal etwas, was in der Forschung aufgenommen
werden muss, diese neuen Möglichkeiten.
Wie hat sich denn das jetzt entwickelt? Wie ist denn da der Stand?
Also wir reden von Astrophysik mit allen Sinnen. Also wir haben vorher schon
darüber gesprochen, dass wir jetzt hören und sehen können.
Die Teilchen könnte man fühlen, also wenn man wirklich sehr empfindliche Hände
hat, also so ein hochenergetisches Neutrino.
Eine Energie, die ungefähr einem von Boris Becker geschlagenen Aufschlagstennisball entspricht.
Also wenn man tatsächlich irgendwie aus Versehen mal...
Als er noch jung war.
Also da kommen sehr, sehr hohe Energien zustande. Und wenn man das Glück hat,
also Neutrino hat halt einen extrem kleinen Wirkungsquerschnitt.
Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ein Neutrino irgendwie ein Atom unseres Körpers
trifft, ist sehr, sehr klein.
Wir werden jede Sekunde mit zigtausenden Neutrinos durchstrahlt.
Aber wenn man einen sehr, sehr guten Empfänger hat, dann hat man manchmal das
Glück, dass man diese sehr hochenergetischen Neutrinos messen kann.
Das erste Mal, dass man Neutrinos im astrophysikalischen Zusammenhang,
also außerhalb der Sonne, also man hat die Neutrinos, die aus dem Sonneninneren
kommen, die hat man ja schon länger gemessen.
Aber das erste Mal, dass man ein astrophysikales Ereignis gesehen hat,
war 1987, als die Supernova in der Magellanschen Wolke explodiert ist.
Und mehrere Neutrinodetektoren auf der ganzen Welt die Ereignisse gesehen haben.
Und es gab auch einen Nobelpreis dafür.
Und das ist tatsächlich auch eine mögliche Quelle, wo Neutrinos entstehen bei
Supernova-Explosionen.
Weil dort werden ja Neutronen, also aus Protonen und Elektronen,
die werden sozusagen zusammengequetscht in ein Neutron und es entsteht ein Neutrino dabei.
Und bei der Supernome-Explosion entstehen also gigantische Mengen von Neutrinos.
Die letztendlich auch dazu führen, dass die Explosion überhaupt stattfindet,
also dass der Stern dann auseinanderfliegt.
Man fragt sich ja immer, wenn alles zusammenstürzt, warum fliegt dann irgendwas
auseinander? Das sind die Neutrinos, die praktisch den Stern auseinander treiben.
Aber die Neutrinos, die jetzt bei Ice Cube gefunden sind, sind noch viel hochenergetischer
als das, was man bei Supernova-Explosionen findet.
Und da ist immer schon lange die Frage gewesen, wo kommen eigentlich die her?
Also wo gibt es solche Beschleuniger, die Teilchen auf so hohe Energien beschleunigen?
Und da spielen natürlich schwarze Löcher eine zentrale Rolle und zwar in zweierlei Art und Weise.
Entweder es handelt sich dabei um solche aktiven galaktischen Kerne,
die ja auch diese Jets aussenden.
Bei diesen Jets gibt es ja auch relativistische Teilchen, die ausgesendet werden
und vielleicht im Zusammenhang mit diesen relativistischen Teilen könnte es
auch sein, dass es Neutrinos beschleunigt werden.
Und eine andere interessante Spekulation ist, dass es sich dabei um sogenannte
Gezeitenzerreißereignisse handelt.
Also man hat ein schwarzes Loch und dann ist ein armes Sternlein,
was um dieses schwarze Loch herumfliegt, was irgendwann mal dem schwarzen Loch
so nahe kommt, dass es quasi durch die Gezeitenkräfte zerrissen wird.
Und dann fängt das schwarze Loch an, diesen Stern aufzuessen.
Und bei der Gelegenheit entstehen auch diese gigantischen, sagen wir mal,
Beschleunigungskräfte.
Ah ja.
Zerplatzte Sterne.
Ja, genau. Und das ist halt so, dass jetzt der Traum des Astrophysikers ist,
dass man eine oder mehrere Ereignisse findet,
die sowohl Gravitationswellen als auch Licht als auch Teilchen erzeugen.
Und in Zukunft werden halt die Empfindlichkeiten dieser Messgeräte immer größer
werden und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man irgendwann mal drei Phänomene gleichzeitig sieht, wird steigen.
Und das ist dann sozusagen die Astrophysik mit allen Sinnen.
Ich selber interpretiere auch noch ein anderes Phänomen als Multimessenger und
zwar haben wir ja zum Beispiel am galaktischen Zentrum schon gesehen,
dass man ganze Sterne als Diagnose benutzen kann,
um zum Beispiel auf das schwarze Loch im galaktischen Zentrum zu schließen.
Das war ja so auch der Nobelpreis vor ein paar Jahren.
Genau, an Reinhard Gensel und Andrea Gess. Und da benutzt man sozusagen die
Sterne selbst als Sensoren.
Das heißt, man beobachtet einfach die Sterne im Zentrum der Galaxis.
Das war jetzt der Nobelpreis und daraus hat man dann geschlussfolgert,
da ist das schwarze Loch.
Genau, man sieht, wie die sozusagen auf elliptischen Bahnen,
genau wie von Kepler vorhergesagt, um dieses schwarze Loch herumsausen.
Und damit kann man etwas dingfest machen, was man nicht sehen kann.
Und sowas ähnliches findet jetzt eigentlich auch schon pausenlos mit Gaia statt.
Also Gaia ist doch diese europäische Astrometrie-Mission, die Milliarden von
Sternen hochpräzise vermisst und man kann anhand der Bewegung dieser Sterne
jetzt auf Phänomene schließen, die man sonst nicht sehen kann.
Und das ist zwar jetzt nicht so im klassischen Sinn Multimessenger,
weil das Licht kommt ja immer noch als Licht auf uns an aber die Signale,
die man interpretiert stammen nicht aus dem Licht selber sondern aus der Bewegung
sozusagen und das ist für mich auch ein zusätzlicher,
Sinn, der da mit in die Astrophysik einfließt Ja.
Die Langzeitbeobachtung die bringt dann sozusagen nochmal Metainformationen heraus Ja,
Weil man ja auf einmal überhaupt erst merkt, hier sind Sterne unterwegs,
die sind nur auf der Durchreise, woher die auch immer gekommen sein mögen.
Das heißt, da muss auch irgendwann mal so ein Beschleunigungsevent gegeben haben,
auf das man unter Umständen dann Rückschlüsse ziehen kann.
Aber wenn man jetzt auf die Multimessenger-Astrophysik als Industrie der Zukunft sozusagen schaut,
dann gibt es da ganz neue Herausforderungen, weil man muss sozusagen erstmal
große Teile des Himmels anschauen, um wirklich einzelne, sehr,
sehr seltene Ereignisse zu sehen.
Also das macht man zum Beispiel durch diese großen Surveys.
Im Moment das Vera Rubin Teleskop hat da am Südhimmel jetzt angefangen zu survern.
Die Gravitationswellen sehen auch den ganzen Himmel. Die Radioteleskope sollen
auch den ganzen Himmel durchmustern.
Also man muss riesige Datenmengen haben.
Gleichzeitig finden diese Ereignisse nur sehr selten statt und wenn eins stattfindet,
dann muss die ganze Welt sozusagen sofort darauf geschaltet werden,
dass die alle das anschauen.
Und in diesem einen Ereignis, was sozusagen mehr oder weniger der Goldstandard
der Multimessenger-Astrophysik im Moment ist, dieses Neutronenstern-Vereinigungsereignis,
Und da gab es dann hinterher ein Paper,
wo 4000 Astronomen drauf standen.
Also praktisch die halbe Astronomiewelt war daran beschäftigt,
dieses eine Ereignis zu studieren.
Und wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen, dass in Zukunft sowas nicht nur einmal in
zehn Jahren passiert, sondern zweimal oder zehnmal am Tag passiert,
dann wird die ganze Dynamik sozusagen unseres Feldes sich ändern.
Was man gleich mehr, worauf man sich überhaupt noch stürzen soll.
Ja, man muss viel automatisieren. Man muss auch Prioritäten setzen.
Man muss mit künstlicher Intelligenz einem helfen zu sagen, wo schaut man jetzt überhaupt hin.
Und wir werden immer mehr lernen müssen, auch interessante Ereignisse zu vergessen
sozusagen, weil wir uns auf noch interessantere Ereignisse stürzen müssen.
Da vielleicht mal kurz nachgefragt, ich meine jetzt AI ist natürlich gerade
in aller Munde, wenn wir hier von AI reden, reden wir natürlich nicht von den
neuen Large Language Models und ähnlichen Geschichten,
sondern eher die klassische Machine Learning Technologie, die ja den anderen
Sachen so zugrunde liegt.
Die basiert ja immer darauf, dass man eben quasi große Datenmengen mit Wahrheiten
bewertet und daraus dann entsprechende Erkennungsmuster ableitet,
die man dann eben auf neue Daten schnell anwenden kann, um zu sehen,
okay, alles klar, da ist irgendwas.
Also so ein Asteroid, der sich sozusagen in vielen Bildern durchbewegt,
wo man sonst vielleicht mit einem bloßen Auge keine Chance hätte,
aber vielleicht auch mit Algorithmen schon Schwierigkeiten hätte,
weil man nicht so genau weiß,
worauf man diese Algorithmen jetzt wirklich drauf tunen soll.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man einfach sagt, hier sind eine Million Bilder,
da ist definitiv ein Asteroid drauf, dann wird eben an der Stelle das Machine
Learning entsprechend getriggert.
Jetzt meine Frage ist, wie sehr hat sich das bewährt in den letzten Jahren als Instrument?
Wie viel Neues konnte dadurch gefunden werden oder wie viele Prioritäten haben sich verschoben?
Also ich würde, ich komme da gleich auf die Frage zurück, aber ich möchte noch
einen Schritt weiter gehen für die Zukunft.
In Zukunft wird es absolut essentiell sein, wenn wir diese gigantischen Datenmengen
anschauen, die die nächste Generation von Teleskopen ausspuckt.
Also zum Beispiel das Square Kilometer Array, das sind ja hunderte von Schüsseln
oder auch hunderttausende von diesen Antennenbäumen,
die da in Australien Daten spucken und dort werden solche riesigen Datenmengen
erzeugt, die man praktisch gar nicht mehr speichern oder überhaupt nicht mehr auswerten kann.
Das Problem ist, dass der Großteil aber eigentlich Rauschen ist.
Der Großteil ist Schmutz und man muss jetzt sehr schnell entscheiden können,
welche Daten habe ich überhaupt auf und welche analysiere ich und welche schmeiße ich weg.
Und da brauchen wir künstliche Intelligenz, Mustererkennung,
die dann sozusagen vor allem das Rauschen rausschmeißt.
Das Rauschen in dem Fall im Radiobereich ist Gott sei Dank, muss man sagen,
nicht stochastisch, sondern systematisch, weil das sind diese ganzen Störstrahlungen
von Elon Musk Satelliten und von Schiffen, die Radio...
Man kennt seine Pappenheimat.
Ja, genau. Und da ist es so, dass man tatsächlich dann künstliche Intelligenz-Methoden verwendet,
um einem zu sagen, welche Daten speichere ich jetzt überhaupt ab und welche
analysiere ich gar nicht.
Und bei der künstlichen Intelligenz ist es aber so, die muss ja trainiert werden.
Das heißt, die kann nur auf Signale reagieren, die eigentlich schon bekannt sind.
Und da ist jetzt das große Problem, dass wir natürlich auch unbekannte Signale
noch entdecken wollen und verhindern müssen, dass die vorher schon rausgeschmissen werden.
Und das wird sich nie hundertprozentig vermeiden lassen. Also wenn man einen
Garten wegschmeißt, wird man immer auch wertvolle Informationen wegschmeißen.
Und in dem Fall ist es tatsächlich so, dass man dann den Himmel als Rückhalt hat.
Also dann muss man halt im schlimmsten Fall, wenn man jetzt eine neue Art von
Signal entdeckt, die man bisher noch nie gesehen hat.
Dann muss man einfach nochmal neu beobachten und dann den Himmel sozusagen nach
solchen Signalen absuchen.
Und jetzt, weil Sie fragen, inwieweit hat das schon geholfen?
Also im Moment diese Machine Learning Techniken werden hauptsächlich angewandt,
um, sagen wir mal, stupide Dinge, die der Mensch macht,
aber immer wieder macht, sozusagen zu vereinfachen und da Hilfe zu leisten.
Es gibt in anderen Feldern wohl, also in der Mathematik.
Jetzt die ersten Hinweise darauf, dass die künstliche Intelligenz auch wirklich
Dinge gelöst hat, neue Beweise gezogen hat, die noch kein Mensch sozusagen geschafft hat.
Aber in der Astrophysik sehe ich im Moment das eigentlich mehr als,
da gibt es ja vor allem auch diese Citizen Science Projekte,
wo man also viele, viele Menschen hat,
die sich dann gleichzeitig Dinge anschauen und da durch die Schwarmintelligenz
sozusagen neue Phänomene erzeugen.
Und an der Stelle kann im Prinzip die künstliche Intelligenz,
kann die Schwarmintelligenz ersetzen sozusagen.
Also das Square Kilometer Array, was wir jetzt gerade erwähnt haben,
ich glaube das haben wir vorhin gar nicht so gesagt, ist halt auch ein neues
Radioteleskop, was eben aus sehr vielen kleinen Teleskopen zusammensetzt,
das in Australien und Südafrika aufgebaut wird und das halt auch diese Pulsar-Entdeckung quasi mit treibt.
Ja, aber auch das Zentrum für Astrophysik hat ja hier ein Ziel,
also hat viele Ziele, aber schon erwähnt, das Einstein-Teleskop soll ein Teil davon sein.
Ja, also das Einstein-Teleskop wäre halt ein weiterer Gravitationswellendetektor,
so wie LIGO, Virgo, Agra, was wir schon besprochen haben,
aber eben tief unter der Erde oder ganz tief in den Bergen sozusagen,
in Felsen, einfach aus den schon erwähnten Gründen.
Da ist Ruhe im Karton und da kann man sich dann irgendwie mehr auf die Wellen selbst konzentrieren.
Wie sieht es denn da aus? Wer treibt das jetzt im Wesentlichen voran und vor allem, wo kommt es hin?
Ja, also das Einstein-Teleskop ist ein zukünftiges europäisches Projekt,
was jetzt schon auf der S3 Roadmap, also European Research Infrastructure Roadmap aufgenommen wurde.
Also es ist eine Priorität in Europa.
Das bedeutet allerdings noch nicht, dass es jetzt auch schon entschieden ist,
dass es gebaut wird oder vor allem finanziert wird. Und im Moment finden eben
gerade die Voruntersuchungen statt, wo es am besten hinkommen sollte.
Und da gibt es schon lange, gab es zwei Plätze, die sich darum gerangelt haben.
Das eine ist Sardinien in Italien und das andere ist das Dreiländereck, Belgien, Niederlande,
Nordrhein-Westfalen, die sogenannte EMR-Region, also Irop-Mois-Rhein-Region.
Euregio Mars Rhein heißt es, glaube ich.
Genau, Euregio Mars Rhein. Und,
Wir als DZA sind ja hier durch diesen Wettbewerb relativ kurzfristig auch noch mit dazugekommen.
Und im Rahmen dieses Wettbewerbs haben wir auch einen einzigartigen Granitstock
hier in der Lausitz identifiziert, der
sich besonders gut für solche Gravitationswellenmessungen eignen würde.
Und wir haben auch gesagt, wir wollen auf jeden Fall in diesem Granitstock eine
Art Untergrundlabor aufbauen, in dem man Technologien für Gravitationswellendetektoren entwickeln kann.
Also sozusagen so ein Geo 600.
Aber unter der Erde. Aber nicht 600, sondern wir reden von 20 Meter Länge.
Also 600 sind die 600 Meter.
Also wir hätten quasi so eine Art Geo 20 dann in der Lausitz, Lausitz 20.
Und wir als DZA haben sozusagen das als eins unserer Ziele.
Das DZA selber hat jetzt sozusagen mit dem Vorschlag,
das Einstein-Teleskop in die Lausitz zu bringen, nicht direkt was zu tun,
sondern das wird hauptsächlich vom Land Sachsen und von der TU Dresden vorangetrieben.
Und dadurch, dass ich Professor an der TU Dresden bin, habe ich da sozusagen auch,
Persönlich war es damit zu tun, aber wir müssen darauf achten,
das DZA selber ist im Moment,
dadurch, dass wir ja von der Bundesregierung gefördert werden,
sind wir nicht beauftragt, jetzt das Einstein-Teleskop zu machen,
weil das ja noch ein Wettbewerb ist, auch innerhalb von Deutschland.
Da ist so ein bisschen politische Sensitivität dafür da sozusagen.
Aber wer wird denn dann letzten Endes die Entscheidung fällen,
also ob es das gibt und wo?
Genau. Letztendlich muss man, um das Einzelnteleskop zu bauen,
braucht man vier Bedingungen.
Das eine ist, dass es technisch machbar ist.
Das andere ist, dass es wissenschaftlich machbar ist. Das dritte ist,
dass es betrieben werden kann.
Und das vierte ist, dass man die politische und finanzielle Unterstützung hat.
Und das vierte ist natürlich das Wichtigste.
Also wir gehen davon aus, dass die Gesamtkosten nahe drei Milliarden sein werden.
Und es ist leider so, dass kein einziges europäisches Land im Moment das Geld
hat, um so viel zu machen. Es muss eine Art...
Großeuropäische Lösung dafür her. Und in dem Sinne ist es ganz gut,
dass es jetzt drei verschiedene Standorte gibt, weil dann könnte man unter Umständen
die Lasten auch ein bisschen verteilen.
Könnte so ein bisschen so ein Gravitationswellen-Zern werden?
Ja, im Prinzip eigentlich, das wäre ideal. Also es ist fast so,
wie das Zern hat ja ursprünglich auch nicht nur reine wissenschaftliche Ziele,
sondern auch vor allem die Kommunikation, die Kooperation zwischen verschiedenen Ländern.
Friedensprojekt könnte man auch sagen.
CERN gab es ja, bevor es wirklich Europa gab. CERN war sozusagen eine Baustelle für Europa.
Für solche Friedensprojekte haben wir auch noch genug Bedarf.
Ja, genau. Und es ist jetzt so, neben der Frage des Standortes ist leider auch
noch eine Unsicherheit über die Geometrie.
Also Einstein-Teleskop ist bisher als ein Dreieck gedacht, so ähnlich wie auch
Lisa ein Dreieck ist, aber es gibt jetzt den Vorschlag, das Dreieck aufzuteilen
in zwei L-förmige, also dass man quasi sowas ähnliches wie LIGO baut.
Und ein L, also die beiden L's müssten mindestens 1000 Kilometer auseinander sein.
Das heißt, es wäre sicher so, dass ein L dann nach Sardinien kommen würde und
ein L nach Nordeuropa, also entweder in die Lausitz oder in die EMR-Region.
Und für mich wäre das eigentlich die Vorzugsvariante, weil dann hätte man sozusagen
nicht Gewinner und Verlierer, sondern da haben alle ein bisschen was davon.
Also dann hätte man praktisch Italien mit im Boot, Deutschland,
Niederlande und so weiter.
Also das Ganze ist eine hochkomplexe und auch letztendlich politische Frage
und zum Schluss hängt es an den Kosten ab.
Und ich glaube, wir sind im Moment in einer Phase, wo wir noch die ganzen Studien
noch nicht abgeschlossen haben.
Also wir wissen weder, ob es wirklich funktioniert an den einzelnen Standorten,
noch was die Kosten sind.
Und deswegen brauchen wir jetzt noch ein Jahr ungefähr, um diese ganzen Randbedingungen
zu klären und dann kann eigentlich eine politische Entscheidung getroffen werden.
Okay, aber das steht auch bald mal an, sagen wir es mal so.
Also nächstes Jahr würde ich sagen oder spätestens Anfang 2027 müsste dann die
Entscheidung getroffen werden.
Wäre jetzt der Unterschied primär, dass man Untergrund ist und ansonsten macht
man eigentlich alles genauso oder werden da noch andere Längen auch erzielt werden können?
Ja, also der Punkt ist, das Einstein-Teleskop selber besteht eigentlich aus zwei Techniken.
Das eine ist einfach eine Erweiterung der jetzt schon existierenden LIGO-Technik,
wobei man nicht mehr vier Kilometer hat, sondern zehn Kilometer.
Das heißt, man kommt entsprechend weiter.
Aber das wirklich Attraktive an dem Einstein-Teleskop ist, dass man eben dieses
neue, gekühlte Interferometer hat, wo man also die Spiegel dann auf 10 Grad
über dem absoluten Nullpunkt abkühlt.
Das heißt also, wir reden von dem sogenannten Xylophon-Design.
Das sind eigentlich zwei Interferometer, die bei zwei verschiedenen Frequenzen gestimmt sind.
Und erst in der Kombination kriegt man eigentlich das Gesamtkunstwerk.
Und dieses gekühlte Interferometer braucht komplett neue Technologien,
also braucht man neue Spiegeltechnologie,
das ganze Kühlsystem, Vakuum und so weiter ist alles viel herausfordernder noch
als bei dem jetzigen LIGO-Design.
Na, dann schauen wir mal, wie
sich das entwickelt. Raumzeit wird dann berichten. Ja, Günther, ich denke.
Wir sind durch.
Das war ein sehr schöner Überblick und auch nochmal eine schöne Vertiefung der
schon existierenden Folgen hier rund um die Gravitationswellenforschung.
Ich wünsche dem DZA, neue Abkürzung, erstmal lernen.
Alles Gute und dass sich das hier alles super entwickelt.
Dann komme ich auch gerne mal wieder vorbei.
Ja, und vielen Dank für das Gespräch. Es ist immer wieder eine Freude, mit dir zu reden.
Freut mich auch sehr. Ja, und vielen Dank natürlich auch fürs Zuhören hier über
Raumzeit. Bald geht es wieder weiter. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.